man that debate last night I got to tell
you the GOP lesser known debates didn't
really care for him didn't know if I
wanted to watch it but when we did it
was incredible V ramaswami stole the
show shattering all the online informal
polls but you know it the corporate
press is claiming he failed he did the
worst I love it the New York Times
saying Nikki Haley actually did the best
and V did the worst meanwhile all of the
trends all the searches are v v v he
absolutely nailed it so of course now
there's a clip going around of ronom
McDaniel who's very upset claiming that
VI voted for Obama here's the best part
Tim Cass got a scoop right after the
show because of course like we know
everybody who's basically at the debate
and uh ra apparently said as VI was
roasting her he's an a-hole he's an
a-hole he's not getting a scent from us
the commented saying this is corrupt
basically calling it corruption so this
is is crazy the top uh the top story
however Donald Trump said on I think it
was Klay Travis's show with buck ston
that Tucker Carlson would be good for VP
it's a question of whether or not Tucker
would do it but we we keep asking this
question because a lot of people are
saying that the GOP debate was actually
the VP debate yeah right is if Chris
Christie wants to be VP for Trump maybe
VI but he says he doesn't want to do it
I personally would love to see a trump
Carlson ticket that would be I don't I
don't see how that loses I I got to be
completely honest but you know who knows
who knows maybe were in the bubble so
we'll talk about that plus a crazy story
in New Jersey a January 6th Manhunt
apparently they're using apcs
helicopters dogs they're they found a
guy they want to arrest him and he fled
so we'll talk about that before we get
started my friends head over to cast
brew.com and by cast Brew Coffee you
must support the show by buying our
official sponsor's product our official
sponsor us of course is our coffee
company if you like the idea that there
will be physical locations all over the
country where people can hang out meet
up and when you walk in there will be
TVs playing the likes of Tim cast the
likes of Steven Crowder stick sexon
Hammer Etc Viva fry then support us by
buying Casper coffee because I got good
news a whole bunch of important
equipment for the cafe came in today so
it's looking like it's going to be up
and running soon if you like the efforts
and the physical meat space go to
casper.com pick up my favorite is
personally Appalachian nights of course
you can get rise with Roberto Jr
breakfast blend that's the number one
favorite and our limited edition R rise
with Roberto Jor get it while it lasts
because once it's gone it's never coming
back but don't forget go to
timcast.net
America by Lauren Southern proud to have
supported Ln uh proud to have supported
Lauren Southern I combined her name into
one word in the production of this and
we're really excited to have it as a
members only on timcast we're going to
be putting up Clips we're wunning a ton
of marketing behind this so just know uh
this documentary is absolutely advocacy
for gun rights and if you believe in the
right to keeping bar arms like we do
watch the documentary learn a little bit
share it with your friends and support
our work don't forget to also smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends I'm I'm
uh joining us tonight I'm I'm gonna
which which name should I use I call him
uh uh Mr guy first named Lecter but his
name's Adam
Johnson hey thanks for having me on uh
you might know me from such acts as the
worst day in history since 9/11
comparable even really um I'm the artist
formerly known as Vietti I am uh oh
that's right you're viati exactly that
was amazing so uh for those that don't
know when this gentleman was taken uh uh
a photo was taken of him via Getty Getty
is a a photography like a photo
Distribution Company and what was it
someone thought that it means from Getty
they thought your name was via Getty yes
this is the Intelligence on Twitter 1.0
that was allowed to circulate and spread
these things right on well uh since then
you've been uh you've been on a bunch of
podcasts you're you've I heard you've
given out little Le to people you of
course the guy that everyone knows
carrying the Leon and waving and we've
had you on before so it's great to have
you back we got a lot to talk about and
especially considering this Manhunt so
it'll be interesting to hear about the
the finer details of of what goes into
these January 6 cases so thanks for
hanging out thanks for having me we got
Shane Cashman hanging out what's up I uh
write for
timcast.net
yeah it's great I'm hanmo I also write
for
timcast.net what I think is real news
but it's impossible to tell these days
Serge is here too yes episode
901 I'm excited to be here Tim let's get
sir when you are when ready the first
story from the hill Trump says he'd
consider Tucker Carlson as running mate
quote I like Tucker a lot I guess I
would Trump said during an appearance on
the clay Travis and buck seon show this
week I think I'd say I would because
he's got great common sense you know
when they when they say that you guys
are conservative or I'm conservative
it's not that we're conservative we have
common sense
we have to have safe borders we want to
have a wall because walls work Carlson
was fired by Fox News blah blah blah
there you go it's uh it's not a very big
uh uh a very verbose story but there is
uh there's one legitimate reason why we
talk about something like this is
because no one really no one really has
a good guess as to who Trump's VP is
actually going to be and I get to ask
this quite a bit I thought Carri Lake
would be good but she's she's running
for Senate in Arizona which makes a lot
of sense and I think that's that's a
better Usef for's time in you know
honestly and uh some people are saying
the ramas Swami especially with how well
he did last night but there's one other
reason why this is our lead story I'm
trying to Manifest this like I
personally would love a trump Carlson
take it because uh uh what we often say
is Trump needs that like San rational
calmer person and I think you know a lot
of people thought it would be disantis
not disantis Tucker Carlson is is
massive and I I think he could he could
push Trump over the over the limit
there's no beating that ticket did Trump
say he was going to pick a woman like a
few months ago no there's just a rumor
about it all time I thought I thought
Tulsi was going to be on the ticket
that's not a Supreme Court vote so it
doesn't have to be a woman and it's not
it's not they're not w i mean what's
Trump who's Trump trying to uh uh
validate what's he trying to prove I
know I I thought because I thought
Carrie was going to be it until she
announced to run for Senate and then
Tulsi said she was willing to work with
Trump tulsy has said stuff I mean chy
position TR there's a couple different
people who are vying for the spot
obviously my thing is if Tucker becomes
the VP that could be fun but I want him
to keep his Twitter show right like the
things that we love about Tucker Carlson
exist because they are outside of
politics in the government and I
wouldn't want to lose that and it's a
question of too like how much money is
Tucker losing by trying to be VP for
Trump right this is a this is a big
challenge you have to really want it
VI he's worth what 600 something million
dollars so I I got to be honest I'm I'm
sure V got to a certain point where he's
like I can't buy anything anymore like
what do I want and he's like well maybe
like one thing you can't buy technically
is a high ranking government position
although let's be real there's a certain
level where it's all for sale and then
there's a certain level where it's not
you know like being VP or president is
something you can only you can buy a
little bit of but you really got to push
the rest and then you've got to
basically sell promises to a bunch of
evil people but if you want to be an
ambassador oh that's a cash deal after
the way he talked to the moderator last
night I was like he'd be a great press
secretary a lot of people are saying
that yeah but I don't think he'd want to
be press secretary I mean the thing that
I like about V is that he feels like he
wants to be in charge of something and I
think that's cool that he wants to sort
of contribute in that way I mean V V's
not my choice president although I
admire him a lot he's great uh I have
some I would want him to be stronger on
restricting legal immigration I've said
that a mil times everyone's bored of
this comment but it is fun to see him
out there right he is shaking up
Politics the way that I think the same
way we feel a Tucker Carlson vice
presidency would shake up this
established thing we're sort of like
let's hearken back to Mike Pence and
this is not to be directly mean to him
but he just sort of faded into the
background and we were like yes that
that one white Evangelical from the
Midwest he he wasn't anything until the
end when he was a big problem right uh
and I think we would expect more from A
A A Carlson vice presidency well I do
think considering we're we're in a wacky
simulation that doesn't seem to make
sense at all you're G to have to think
crazier in terms of VP pick right Kanye
West you know go forward that was Flo
around a year ago yeah it was Trump
trump West was floated around Kanye on
Tru social I think wrote a thing saying
I will let Trump be my VP right I'm sure
Trump was like thank you so much very
gracious of him yeah I mean I think the
other thing is that we are seeing people
who are at the front like in some ways I
do think running for president for a lot
of people is just to raise your National
profile so realistically the people who
are creating the short list of potential
VP candidat
are looking beyond the people who are
appearing appearing on the debate stage
I mean Biden picked off the debate stage
Cala dropped out then she got her
facelift it was obvious she was going to
be VP these are historical facts why you
laughing at me but you know with a lot
of presence in the past it's a I mean
who had heard of Sarah Palin really
before she got tapped to bvp there are
people that were not aware of and I
wouldn't be surprised if Trump's team is
expanding Beyond people who hold
government positions right yeah but I
mean who's it like the the the goal of
the VP is to capture the demographic
that the the the candidate doesn't
capture and so I think this is what uh
who who was saying this was it uh was it
Robbie maybe Robbie Starbucks I'm not
sure they said what demographic does a v
capture that's he's he's he's basically
got Trump voters already you know that's
this is the funny thing he says all the
perfect things that every Trump voter
wants to hear and they're going to smile
as they vote for Trump and say oh hey VI
and they're going to hit Trump exactly
so he's got to like if even if he was
going to be the VP is he gaining
anything for that ticket right that was
the argument with Mike Pence that he
gave him he gave Trump Evangelical
voters in the midwest he locked that
down but I don't know if that's Cas I
think that's why people want there's
this ongoing thing that it'll definitely
be a woman because you know it was like
Suburban women are the ones who pulled
away from Trump the most so
theoretically if you put a lady in the
VP office you know that will maybe win
them back I don't think that's actually
true I just think that's like CU then
who's it going to be like Christine and
maybe but they're going to push Nikki
Haley that's exactly what I was thinking
welltory with Trump already right she
worked in the Trump Administration
absolutely I think their relationship's
too contentious I don't think he would
take Nikki Haley yeah but look at look
at the the GOP debates in 2016 you know
what I mean like it was contentious and
then everyone got past it this this
always happens Kamala called you know
Biden a
racist right that she's like no work
politics yeah right I think uh there's a
lot of women who are disaffected
liberals who like RFK and that maybe
there's an RFK Trump thing happening
down the ticket is perhaps yeah I mean I
also think that we look down to like
attorney general levels like Chris
kobach from Kansas like there are other
people who have interesting points I
mean the thing that rally Trump voters
in my opinion back in 2016 really was
the wall in Immigration that set him in
a lot of ways he was already different
from a lot of candidates but when he
said I'm going to build the wall that
was something a lot of people rallied
around so to pick someone female male
whatever who is taking a strong stance
on immigration would in some ways
reignite the base and we know that the
the immigration crisis the border is
something that is starting to be a
conversation in more moderate and left
leaning spheres progresses will probably
never vote for anyone who would build a
wall but there are other people who are
feeling the burdens that might come
Adams wants wall I'm feeling worried
it's going to be Nikki Haley's VP cuz
people have have floated that before and
every everyone everyone in the room just
shook their head Nikki Haley is John
McCain's skeleton in a wig like we can't
have her anywhere near the White House
and that and that performance last night
was terrible I can't see her not
according to the New York Times well
they see and the New York Times
definitely knows how Republican votes
two movies one
screen world one of the other big
stories we got is uh CNN New York Times
AP and Reuters journalists embedded with
Hamas going to the attack on Israel so
it's like they knew but uh right right
now a bunch of media workers are
protesting the New York Times because
they're not favorable
to they say Palestine but we know what
they mean by that so that just helps you
understand the kind of people who work
for the New York Times yep yep yeah yeah
it's interesting I said this morning
Nikki Haley was so excited to go to war
that she premature bombed on stage last
night that's a good one I just still
can't get over her heel tweet being like
I wear them it doesn't make any sense
it's so annoying she said I wear heels
for ammunition what does that her heels
are ammunition she's giving women a bad
name everywhere it makes you never want
to wear heels again be associated with
that comment Peli said she would use her
heels to stab the uh Riders she had an
interview she talked about that she
would have taken off her heels and stab
people with them Nikki was referencing
probably is that what she's claiming she
uses she said I wear heels but they're
not for fashion they're for ammunition
but then I saw that video of like a
reporter throwing a shoe at Bush like oh
yeah yeah oh man I I I remember when
that happened the the shoe throw ah
those are the
days so
old and you see like Secret Service
busting into the back like 5 minutes
late to be honest like it was all it was
not their best moment I mean maybe
that's what she me maybe she was just
preparing to throw her shoes across at
VI she was pretty angry at him Bush can
dodge shoes and questions about why he
went to war for 20 years yeah yeah and
the left has accepted him back into like
the good graces yeah he threw the
opening pitch recently yeah Kimel had
him on like a year or two to talk about
his paintings this is the thing so I
went to Southern MTH University in
Dallas and his Presidential Library is
on that campus and I had a a liberal
Professor tell me at one point she's
like nowhere in America is he more
popular than at this campus CU he would
come to like our basketball games we
chant USA like it's not you like his
politics but it's like this is kind of
hilarious we have a president who just
sits in all of he like would randomly
show up in class wow I do need to point
out though when VI said Dick Cheney and
3-inch heels the moderator cut him off
but he does say and we've got two of
them on stage tonight yeah that actually
sliced the joke so everyone immediately
like I tweeted I was like wow he called
Nicki Haley Dick Cheney and some people
are like I think he's talking about Ron
and then I played the clip back and he
literally says and we have two of them
he was talking about both of them but
the moderator cut them off the bouet
thing to me is so silly like we're a
bunch of grown men talking about other
men's feet like is this politics now
this this is the important
thing I've heard the the argument about
you know integrity and honesty and you
should be honest about yourself and if
you you have to wear you know lifts if
it was some type of decision made by
your team to be you could you're taller
than you said yes to it well maybe you
shouldn't have said yes to that I think
it's cuz you can't take a joke I don't
care how tall you are it's just like
that him or the team can't take secur
and it also shows who he would staff
himself with right like again I thought
D Sanz would have been a good VP pick uh
I'm not I I am very loathed to short
anyone when potentially we have a long
long time it's going to take decades to
turn America around in my opinion but
yes uh you know with all of everything
that's happened in boot gate it just
makes it seem like he is around people
who do not feel confident with doing and
so in response they're on an attack mode
and I think that's what makes Trump in
comparon even more attractive to voters
because through everything he is
ultimately the center of the room this
overconfident this Brash guy he's not
the most sve he's not the most
professional always but he acts from a
place of confidence and I think that's
what America's Americans really crave
right now in leadership let's let's jump
to uh this next story this was uh big
news that broke after the debate uh Tim
Cass with the scoop R McDaniel overheard
trashing VI ramaswami and debate
audience saying he won't get a sent from
us he's an a-hole total a-hole Danel
said a source who was sitting near
McDaniel told timcast news that she was
uh she was not attempting to keep her
voice lowered apparently tons of people
heard this and she called him an a-hole
and declared the party would not be
giving him a scent he's an a-hole total
a-hole he's desperate because he's doing
bad in the polls he won't be getting
Ascent from us she was in complete
meltdown over V the V The Source said
this was in the middle of the audience
with an earshot of at least 50 people so
apparently after it after the debate V
apparently was having like was talking
to her at the edge of the stage now we
have this from the New York Post Ron
McDaniel claps back at VI grami he's at
4% and needs a headline this is in line
with exactly what uh the timcast news
source said that she was saying in the
audience and she went on to say
something like uh let me see if they
have it in this story because VI like
struck back here here we go she says I
know that VI is kind of newer to the
party he voted for Obama so he may not
know that ramaswami claimed he did not
vote in any presidential election
between 08 and 2016 voting for
libertarian Michael badner in 04 and
former president Trump in 2020 so she's
just losing it and outright lying now
about VI I I got to tell you I I think I
know what what Ron McDaniel and the GOP
establishment is doing what do we keep
hearing from the santis people oh it's
Trump's fault that we're losing all
these elections it's Trump's fault oh
the Trump candidates are losing they are
in intentionally sabotaging Republicans
and we hear it non-stop we just had Jan
talking about how he gets he gets uh
basically cut off and they they sabotage
him they're doing it so they can say see
Trump's bad for the party give us back
the power let us be in control and shut
your mouths I saw it firsthand how
Antiquated the GOP is at the debate in
California you know these the Nikki
Haley the disantis they all walk off the
stage no one one really cares when they
walk into the Press Room you know they
get the the Hannity treatment and they
go away Cary Lake and vake were the
people that people the real press
swarmed like you know and that was they
were the center of attention and Nome
which is an issue because like Hannity
loved being around Nome so much which is
bizarre but like everyone else no one
cared you know Chris Christie doesn't
even go to the The Press Room you know
literally no one cares is like the
Kathleen Kennedy for the GOP like she
just keeps losing for us and if we look
at how if I get this wrong correct me
but even during the 2022 midterms we saw
that McCarthy was not supporting America
First candidates right we saw Yes we saw
funding going actually against those
candidates and this is the game they
playing for a long time because you have
someone that comes in that is
anti-establishment you know it's the
only reason I voted for Trump in 2020 I
didn't vote in 2016 for him I didn't
vote at all but you see these things
happen you're like man maybe there
actually is a voice pushing forward we
actually can have meaningful change yeah
it makes me wonder I mean if her smear
to him is that he voted for Obama you
know I believe him I believe he didn't
but if if he did and now he's running
for pres that's a huge change and I
think it would be interesting to talk to
someone and say how did you come from
either not voting or voting for Obama to
wanting to really be a part of a very
serious America first movement it's sort
of a Mis opportunity on her part where
she's saying you're threatening my power
and she can't see what what's actually
good for the party they're elitist
they're upholding the uni party and they
hate Outsiders like Trump that they Cary
lake so you know well like she's saying
he's not gonna get a sent from us
I mean V has a lot of money I'm sure he
doesn't want to spend it all in his
campaign I'm sure donors are good and
things like that but like he doesn't
actually need it and exactly and this is
how you get independence within the
party the V does not need to bend the
knee to the corporate lobbying interests
and that's why he's able to say things
that has that has us all riled up and
all excited cuz he's like I don't need
your money screw off you suck and then
they're like well I'm not going to give
you any money he's like I got more money
than you do exactly I have a deep
concern for these people let's let's
just say Trump not in office you know
we're with someone who doesn't have
Trump money or vake money do you think
they're going to come after them any
less than the way they came after these
two people who can actually afford their
court fees no it's going to be the same
tactic being afford we are we are in
this now they will attack anyone who
comes in anyone and make the taxpayers
pay for it people need to understand R
McDaniel likes the Democrats more than
she likes Viv more than she likes you
she will absolutely shake the hand and
smile uh uh you know shake the hand of
like Gavin new and smile and everything
while calling V an a-hole
the the the establishment Republican
party sabotaged Republicans helping
Democrats win because they did not want
to lose power in the party establishment
yes exactly which is the opposite of
America first but you know what man look
Patrick B David put out a poll and said
who do you think you know won or
whatever and V 80 90% I think it was
like 91 92% and then you look at uh like
the New York Times and everything and
they're like oh he did the worst MH the
machine hates VI but you know what VI is
effectively the right leaning leader of
the millennial generation and I don't
think I don't see any other way to
phrase this he is running for president
he is 38 years old imagine where he's
going to be in 10 or 15 years he is
going to be one of the most prominent
personalities speaking to the more uh
Centrist to conservative uh factions
within the millennial generation and and
to a great extent j z but when we hear
the things that he's saying it very much
resonates with many of us you know in
it's like a wide an range maybe you can
even say the key demo because Nikki
Haley's not talking to anybody who's she
talking to Ronda sandis a little bit but
he's still trying to capture that old
neocon energy the's the only one who it
seems like is saying you'll see me in
four years right V also is the only one
who really speaks like a human being on
that stage you know it sounds like he's
done podcasts like you know RFK as well
uh Tucker obviously these people can
talk with depth for a long amount of
time and not just exem charismatic oh
yeah and you you can't you can't
manufacture that I mean that's just the
way it is I think one of the best parts
about vake is that he is so young and
full of energy I mean I just
fundamentally believe that he is capable
of doing a lot and that's good for the
party the fact that they will not
Embrace him number one tells us that
he's probably good I mean I if if Ron
mcdel doesn't like them that is a reason
to maybe research them and be interested
a little bit more uh but he's going to
last like if you know he doesn't get
what he wants out of this election I'm
sure he will do something else and
that's what I think young Republicans or
young conservative leaning people even
Independents need to see that it's not
just fall in line or and stop or or stop
it's it's keep going no matter what
we're taking it over I do think gen Z
will probably wake up in the next 5 to
10 years because they're still very
young you know I don't blame them for
being young they're just young but as
they continue to live life and they
don't have an opportunity to buy a home
they're paying 800 bucks for for buying
a car because interest rates are also
high on those as well they're going to
realize what we're voting for is not
working they will see the effects of
their decisions but it's going to take
some time and the will be there four
years from now to say hey are we ready
now but I've said this so many times I
don't think people are ready yet I think
there will have to be a measure of
suffering that that will have to
continue yep and it's sad however uh I I
agree with you I will say the only thing
that matters to me is that we win
culturally because for for too long
people on the right conservatives have
thought we got to win the votes we got
to win the votes and Democrats have been
saying get them when their kids it's
like the cigarette companies yo get them
while they're young get them to smoke
early and so this is the general idea my
concern right now I look to what the
daily wire is doing with bent key and
I'm like that's huge that's huge give
give families an opportunity to give
their kids something that's not W
garbage and then what I'm you know what
we're talking about doing is we put out
a documentary uh infringed with Laurence
we put game of money with uh uh Ben
Stewart we're making way more and the
goal there is what are we going to do
are we going to are we going to take the
money that we make from running this
like doing this show and and doing these
other shows and then try and campaign to
win elections that to me is NS yeah but
we put out these documentaries we keep
pushing them and we create a library of
entertaining content we make music we're
working on the skate show the boonies we
got pro skateboarders coming down we
want to own this space so uh shout out
to Richie Jackson pro skateboarder he
took a picture oh man I love this I wake
up in the morning I'm sitting on a
toilet and I'm scrolling through
Instagram because that's what we do and
I see Shredder news it's a skateboarding
news outlet and sure enough there's the
picture that Richie posted the other day
with Lauren Southern pro skateboarder
taking a picture with Lauren Southern
holding fake guns their toys and it's
said with the infringed logo and I think
he just did it cuz I thought it was
funny and it created a quote quote
backlash in the skate culture and I'm
like this means that these teenagers
they're uh uh they're they're like
Richie's Richie's an amazing dude and
he's he's like a superstar you know he's
he's a very uny birthday too by the wayy
birth Rich Y and uh there are people go
up to him and they're like dude you're
my favorite skater they're so excited to
meet him and they see that he's fearless
and he's and he's willing to support
things that he agrees with he's not
scared of what these activists say to
him that's what we want to build and so
I can look to the V and I cheer them on
I can looked all the voting stuff but
I'm like let me let me tell you exactly
what our plan is and I'll simplify it in
this way a story some of you may have
heard me me say or a general idea pro
athlete says I'm too scared to speak up
about males competing against females
because I'll lose my sponsors then I say
okay our company makes enough money to
sponsor you we'll sponsor you will you
speak up now and they'll go oh okay
great then the other company will say
hey if you you post those Instagram
things arguing about politics we're
going to drop you as a sponsor and then
that athlete can
say however much money you think you'd
lose from me posting this image you're
going to lose tenfold when I include you
in my complaint I make more than enough
money with my other sponsors I don't
need you anymore so I've been telling
pro skateboard companies this and
they're they're s they're salivating why
many of these guys in Pro skateboarding
hate wokeness they're Rebels they want
to push security guards to do stupid
garbage I tell them not to do that by
the way and they're walking on eggshells
but they're scared they'll get attacked
and I said don't worry we're going to
flood the Zone we're going to build
media and we are going to be the the the
tip of the spear on on this one and then
once we pave the way you can say don't
look at me but the money will be there
that's the point of building culture
then the young people who are growing up
are going to see Fearless Freedom punk
rock Etc we can say what we want you
can't shut us up and that's how we push
back on the W garbage I don't think
you're creating culture you're creating
counterculture then that's that's what
you're producing and to Hannah's point
it's not going to going to take four
years not an election it's a generation
when these genz have kids the ones they
don't abort right their kids aren't
going to want to follow what the parents
are doing kids kids want to have counter
thoughts to their parents thoughts you
you you can't immediately assume that
genz is is leftist or liberal I just saw
a poll today that gen Z out of I I think
all generations has the more males who
reject the uh identifying as feminists
so let me let me phrase it there was a
chart saying like uh genen Z Millennial
X and Boomer
and genz males are the least likely to
claim they're feminists so it's like you
know and the females are the most likely
which is they're angry at females
because they're not getting laid because
the top 5% that are attractive are the
ones getting all the swipes on twinter
that's that's that's what's going on and
they're just mad at females and they're
rejecting it I think the youngest
generation is used to being divided and
I think they will not stay that way as
they become older right as they age into
their 20s 30s things will change and
right now we're seeing a reckoning they
are now turning to the people who you
know LED them here right when we see
everything that's going on with Israel
and Palestine and go and and Hamas they
are saying you know we believe one thing
but the establishment believes believes
another thing do we even belong here
anymore I think a lot of them will shift
more independent I don't think it'll be
a perfect uh you know just they all
March right over and register as
Republicans but I think generally they
are used to being divided and so
therefore they won't mind being
unaffiliated and I I got to stop you
there I think you're completely wrong
they don't hate women they they aren't
mad they're not getting laid they're
angry that feminism has created a world
in which women are going on only fans
and not seeking relationships and these
are guys many of these men are just like
look I just want to have like a wife and
have a family and there are many women
saying the exact same thing but women
are feeling pressured like they have to
go and work and men are struggling to
compete in this hypers sexualized hookup
culture Marketplace so you're getting
young guys who are just like this is
effed this does not work women of course
I think the reason why gen Z females are
the most likely to say they're feminists
they have to it's it's peer pressure
it's social pressure that women are more
susceptible to social pressure than men
are so the guys are just like get out of
here with that stuff I can't stand it
and what do they want guys probably just
want to get married I mean look there
are there are there are many guys who
just want to get laid that's true but I
think the average guy just wants to get
like married yeah I I think that's fair
and I think there is intense social
pressure I mean I felt this way when I
was you know in public high school doing
whatever and they were like well if
you're a woman you have to be a feminist
you have to be a feminist you have to be
a feminist and you know every
generation that is surveyable right now
this a few research study the majority
of all age groups identify as feminists
but yet women are unhappy and hopeless
so we know I mean there's a reason that
Jezebel shuddered today right like the
feminist publication couldn't survive
yet we have Eevee magazine on the rise I
mean there is a desire well explain
explain Eevee so Eevee is um I I just
know as an alternative women's magazine
they particularly pay attention to more
traditional values and they promote
femininity over feminism and I love the
work that they do U and I think that
they are you know one of the reasons I
got into them that they were just
interested in you know classical Beauty
they're not trying to make you cut all
your hair off and dress dress
Ambiguously they're just saying you
should like being woman and that's cool
and I think there are lots of young
women who are looking for that for and
and the thing is women skew towards
wanting you know emotional and social
acceptance and that can be a strength I
don't mean to like downplay it at all
but that means if all the women around
you say I'm a feminist and men are bad
then you are likely to also think maybe
that's the way and we have new Outlets
coming out that are offering them an
alternative so even though the majority
of young women today gen z may say
they're feminist right now I wonder if
that will change and you'll get the
stories that are like I regret
identifying as feminist my mom raised me
my my intense feminist mother raised me
and she was wrong I love her but but
this was not the right path because
ultimately the genders aren't supposed
to be enemies they're supposed to be
partners mhm a lot of it's going to be
too late though a lot of these girls who
are only fans who are doing these things
they're it's going to be too late for
them men men don't want that men do not
want that it's crazy every day we see
more and more stories about women being
I could quit my job and I did only fans
and wow I made so much money and it's
just like wow that's poison absolute
poison but this is what modern leftist
and feminism promotes the sex positive
culture and it is really fascinating
that what are we getting women sports
are slowly you know males are competing
in women sports and women are quitting
their careers like as doctors nurses
police officers as professional fighters
to do porn they're the most sexually
objectified they have ever been and this
is what feminism is saying like good
this is what we wanted unless a man does
it then it's bad except also who's
paying for your only fans men are
clicking men are paying that's right I
know a lot of women who you know adapted
those feminist qualities throughout High
School never got married and now they're
my age I'm 38 and they still act like
they're in high school you know or
college so it's a lot of Millennials
dude this is what this is what I've been
saying about Millennials uh why I lo the
millennial generation they they have
this mentality that you can't be a boss
this is communism okay and this is a
component of Communism and I think it
comes from college I think it comes not
it's not it's not at at its root College
it's what college has become
you've got a kid he grows up from 0 to 5
does nothing at 5 years old he begins
kindergarten maybe there's preschool
there in daycare and stuff and little
bits here and there but mostly nothing 5
years old to what 13 you've got grade
school they're told what to do then high
school they're told what to do then
College they're told what to do they
graduate at 22 and they say what should
I do now the government comes around and
says we'll tell you what to do this is
why I think we we don't see very many
Millennial politicians it's why why we
don't see uh uh we're not it's why you
you get all these Millennials
complaining about Boomers have all the
wealth they they're holding the wealth
and I'm like it's because Millennials
aren't doing anything and I think the
reason is Millennials have this mental
block where they think they're not good
enough and someone else is in charge so
this is and that's exemplified by
looking at a a presidential election
with a bunch of octogenarians or seog
genarian why is everybody so old don't
get me wrong Ronda Sanz is up there okay
VI of course up there but it's few and
far between and again Boomers control
the wealth why Millennials keep saying
the Boomer is my boss instead of saying
I'm going to be my own boss and start a
business then they go but it's so hard
to get money it's so hard to do ask any
of these people how they started their
business they started from nothing look
at the business we're building here we
started with nothing quite literally
like I got a job I saved up money I got
a better job I saved up money and then I
started my Independent Business practice
and slowly built up to this point
there's no secret it's sacrifice you
know grind through the mud and the dirt
work your fingers to the Bone and build
it up I think you also have to be
willing to accept responsibility though
and I think that's what a lot of
Millennials don't want they have this
desire to stay childish in so many ways
and that keeps them from you know all
good things take a little bit of risk
right so if you really want to be in
Char run your own business you have to
accept that that will come with some
responsibility you may have to be you
know responsible for proving your own
health insurance or whatever it is or
you don't get that and they would
ultimately rather have someone to blame
you know I think
when I if I'm watching someone play a
video game and they're bad at it I get
really frustrated and I'm just like can
I give me the controller like dude you
you're not jumping right let me do it
and then I'll be like never watch me
play a video game I I'm like leave I'll
play I'll do my thing I I struggle with
watching other people try to solve
problems that I feel like I could solve
faster and better and call me arrogant
call me cocky call me call me whatever
you want that is the the mentality that
leads me to to look my 40-year-old boss
in the eye when I'm 16 and say you're a
I could do your job better than
you I quit and I leave I'm not kidding
when I was 16 I was working at a fast
food restaurant and I I guarantee you I
could have done a better job than the
manager they hired why because I had
experience doing man managerial work at
my family's Cafe when I was 12 so I'm
like I saw my mom do all this stuff she
taught me some of it then I see a guy
who gets hired has zero experience but
you know he was an assistant manager you
know at a different shop so when he
comes in he doesn't understand how
anything Works everything's kind of
getting jammed up everything's bad like
time scheduling is bad and I'm like bro
I've been here longer than you I know
how this works better than you they
hired you for arbitrary reasons so I
said I ain't doing this I'm out I'm
going to do my own thing what do I do
I've done a bunch of things in my life
to make money one day I'm like I need to
pay my rent so I took my guitar and I
went down and I played in the subway in
Chicago and then I got yelled at and
said you need a permit so I went I went
downtown paid the five bucks got the
permit went back got into a fight with
some guy who was dancing with the
football because he's like this is my
spot and I'm like okay and I would make
probably 15 bucks an hour just playing
guitar I'd play for 2 or three hours top
40s I'd make like 45 bucks and then i'
go put in the bank and then I'd be done
like that was so much fun I'm just
jamming playing the guitar then I
figured something out I went to Wrigley
baseball field right as a game was
ending I made $200 in one hour cuz
everybody's wasted and I was like wow
why would I get a job and all my friends
were like I'm broke I need job and I'm
like look man I'll be honest I've had
jobs right I went and worked at a bar it
was hard to find jobs I worked at the
airport for a couple years and then it
was actually after the airport I decided
I'm going to go just play guitar in the
street and make money and then
eventually I got bored and worked for
nonprofit and stuff like that but
ultimately it always comes down to what
I see today is people who
say it's it's either the get out of my
way and let me do it or I ain't touching
that that's your problem I think you're
explaining a solution-minded um solution
oriented mindset right a lot of kids
don't learn how to fail because we just
do it for them and a lot of Millennials
they weren't allowed to fail they got
other trophies they were just pushed
through grades and they never had to
figure out how to find a solution to get
better at something my kids I love when
they fail it is the most exciting thing
that I see from them because they only
get to talk about finding Solutions yeah
well how did you fail at this thing what
thing did you do wrong well what could
you try differently next time and my
kids they find solutions they they fail
a couple of times and they get better at
it I wish wasn't rare but I do the same
with my kids and you they you got to let
them fail you know that's that's the big
lesson I think the system we're in
infantilizes young men and women and so
they're risk averse like you were saying
earlier and you know you can see that
even in Little Things la oh and super
lazy but like even little things like
they they're afraid to pick up the phone
you know cuz they're afraid of even
answering and talking to a real person
you know like that's crazy I recorded a
segment today which is going coming out
tomorrow on my uh timcast news channel
of this welome and getting pulled over
for a DUI she's driving the wrong way
down the road she smells like alcohol
she gets pulled over and she admits to
having several drinks and the cop is so
nice and she's like I'm nonbinary and
he's like okay man I'm sorry I okay I'll
I'll try my best and then he's like can
you walk in a straight line for me and
she's like no because I have mental
health issues and like generational
trauma because and then when he finally
decide there's one point where he's like
follow my finger no ma'am follow my
finger I'm trying but you're trying to
intimidate me he's like I don't know how
I'm doing that then when he finally
decides to arrest her she's like dude
you're you're being a white man and it
this is this is what's going on in their
brains she was driving the wrong way
down the road into oncoming traffic
after having several drinks I don't want
to say she's drunk I don't know she had
three drinks maybe and so she gets
pulled over for it m get out of the car
and she's like I don't want to get out
of my car I goes we're pass that now out
of the car you know St by and she's like
okay and then she said you're being a
white man what think about the mental
perspective she must have on driving
drunk the wrong way down the road and
it's the fault of the officer for being
a white man did she go to everg green
College where Brett Weinstein was
remember like they were yelling at the
at the guy for being like the hand
movements are aggressive you know put
them down but they were lying about that
because after he stopped they all
laughed at him oh yeah no they were they
were using that against him for sure did
he identify himself as a white Bale how
did how did she know that's right no she
just used it like a slur which is also
telling right what if she had said like
oh you're acting like a Korean man like
would that mean something different no
only to insult him as a white man one of
the funniest things is she goes I have
really bad social anxiety and then he
goes you and me both and then she goes
okay like uh oh your stupid lie and
excuse and victimization didn't work on
this guy she tried every card in the
book and then she got arrested but this
is the generation that gets created it
is not all Millennials obviously you
know I'm a millennial I don't know how
old are you 38 we're all Millennials
look at us sitting here oh those dang
Millennials they ruined millenni
millennialism they ruined the generation
yeah I had a grandfather I think it made
a big difference yeah I think
grandfathers are like the uh they're The
Gatekeepers of the old ways and most of
our generation can't even find their
fathers totally that's so sad you spend
a lot of time with your grandfather
sorry I did actually he was he's my hero
this man uh couple of motorcycle
accidents um last one he rolled 15 times
he had multiple skin grab surgery eye
hanging out of his face you know they
told him you have brain damage you're
never going to exist the way you did
this man went back to school and got a
PhD and he got several of letters of
certification find they spent the rest
of his life helping drug addicts
alcoholics this man is my hero my
grandpa once uh I may have told a story
I I made a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich when I was staying with him
when I was 18 and he was he was going to
give me a ride somewhere and then he's
like come on let's get out of here and
then I I looked down at the sandwich I
was like throw it away he's like what's
wrong with it and I was like it's got
mold on it he walks over grabs it shoves
it in his mouth and he goes do you have
any idea what we ate dur in the
depression let's go that my grandpa
exactly I was going to say like it's so
important to talk to the older people in
your life and if you have a grandfather
grandma like I I interviewed mine for
hours before he passed away for years
you know I have multiple hours of
interviews with him because I could
learn about you learn about so much time
before you hear War you know he was a
cop in in New York City in the 70s when
it was all on fire then he was a hearse
driver so kind of like ran the gamut of
like death war life you know marriage
and all these things and a lot of people
don't have that access to someone who's
and also you to Foster family
relationships right like I my parents
were older when they had kids anyways
but also my parents were IM immigrants
to the us so we didn't see our
grandparents that often and I think
about now you know technology is so
Advanced where like your kids
grandparents could call them on the
phone they could have access and it's
like we don't appreciate what we have in
that in that connection because we're so
busy saying the older generation did
this and you know I'm I'm here to blame
the Boomers for all kinds of stuff too
but also they were your parents you
should get to know them and I think part
of growing up is accepting that your
parents are humans and have fault and
have failed and so many people aren't
ready to do that even though they are at
an age where they could become parents
and learning from their mistakes kind of
like how you watch your kids learn from
their mistakes right CU they got a ton
of they can tell you about too I still
have dinner with my grandma once or
twice a month or being all the kids over
CU it's important this is why I hate Rah
emanuel's brother I forget his name but
he wrote that article I think it might
have been in Time Magazine Jim Emanuel
maybe I don't know I don't I forget but
he wrote the thing about how old people
should let them let themselves die and
we shouldn't have a we should have a
society without old people and I'm as
I'm reading that article my kid was
downstairs yeah with his great grandma
learning about history the same way I
did you know from the same woman you
know from from her perspective and I was
like this is just straight up evil but
they don't want you to have family I
mean the nuclear family like the mom dad
children relationship is really
important but the extended family is a
gift and itself and if you have a strong
extended family with good values who can
support each other then you are less
relyant on the government enemies which
is exactly what they don't want exactly
they want to destroy the family and it
goes back to in INF infanti everybody so
that when you are 2122 the government
steps in momy dad there are certain
countries I think Iceland is one of them
that will give grandparents tax breaks
or some kind of you know income or
whatever if they are going to instead of
you know enrolling the kid in daycare or
state sponsored School whatever if they
stay with the grandparents and the
grandparents are the ones who take care
of them while the parents are working or
doing whatever that means that like
instead of a stranger your parents who
potentially you have a good relationship
with would be spending time with your
children in an environment that tends to
your child's specific need because they
love and care about them like that's a
great system now here's the challenge we
all recognize this issue because we were
raised well and there are other people
who don't care at all because they were
not you can't go to one of these
Millennials and be like listen it's very
important and here's why because they're
going to say you're nuts I don't care
where's the sex party at and then when
they're when they're oh man I am not
looking forward to aging Millennials
right one of the one of the debate
questions is about raising the age of
retirement and also security it is going
to be wild when you have a whole bunch
of single isolated childless
individuals like just demanding the
government pay their bills for them what
what what what is the marketplace going
to look like the government's going to
give you uh 3D printed suicide pods I
think you know what I I I I would not be
surprised J just got an erection after
hearing that yeah that's that's why maid
is emerging most likely seriously I
would not be surprised if the younger
Generations forcefully enact some kind
of homing for aging Millennials and I'll
tell you why right now the market for
you know uh look Millennials are in
their 30s it's like it's like early 30s
maybe late 20s but mostly early 30s to
late
30s these are people who can still run
and jump and somersault and backflip and
eat pizza but H man once you're getting
around 37 38 you got to cut the salt
down you got to be careful what you're
eating you got to start stretching more
in these things imagine what's going to
be like when they're 50 and 60 and they
can't do any of these things but they're
still single and childless what will
they do we are going to have a wave of
stories about a strange stench coming
from an apartment building MH it is not
these these happen periodically it's
like neighbors notice a strange smell
and found Edna had passed away several
days earlier happened down the road for
me in my hometown it is going to be it
is going to be nuts and there's I I
would not be surprised if a log gets
passed where it's like checkups have to
be performed on anybody over the age of
65 because of how many dead bodies are
being found isolated in their homes I'll
tell you what's scary a scary thought is
that you could be 25 years old take a
shower in the morning in your one
bedroom apartment you're single you got
work and you step out of the bathtub and
you slip and you hit your head on the on
the sink and you're dead and no one
knows and then a week goes by and
they're like damn at 25 now it's rare
right it gets increasingly more likely
when you get older and you start falling
and you're out of shape it's going to be
nuts when we have like I mean it's going
to be tens of millions more Millennials
who are single and childless in their
60s living in studios it's going to it's
going to be absolutely nuts they're
going to so and and if there's no family
member to put them in a home what
happens Mass elderly homelessness of
Millennials and then I so one of the
things that may happen is they're going
to vote for weird crazy communist
garbage and that may start that that
will absolutely extract from the younger
generation already Social Security is
insolvent the older generation is
getting paid and the younger
generation's paying for it but we're not
having kids so population's going to
decline then Social Security won't be
maintained and Millennials are going to
be old and they're going to say no I
paid I get my fair share and the Young
Generation is going to be like we can
run faster than you we're going to send
in the law enforcement to bring you to
homes and that's that's going to be your
welfare what scares me also is the
amount of ssris those depressed people
are going to be taking and how many more
people are going to be on these pills
and how crazy they're going to get you
know after all that depression up to the
meterse exactly to say they are trying
so hard to make the neuralink in the
meterse so then they can just strap you
in the Pod sink the Pod into the ground
lock it up and then you're in The Matrix
and it doubles as the suicide pod I
looked at the think it's like 30 or 40%
SSRI intake across the past 10 years
they it's up 30 or 40% it's a ridiculous
number yeah it's insane it's insane it's
really scary and there's not like most
people who take ssris are just on them
forever which I don't want to be you
know too General about there are people
who really benefit from it but they
aren't saying have you can considered
through your lifestyle changing your
lifestyle have you consider changing
your diet have you considered you know
exercising more have you thought about
you know stop hanging out with all these
people that make you miserable instead
it's just sort of like continue to pay
for therapy and ssris indefinitely
forever give me a pill why is it not
working yeah you mean I can't keep
living immorally but it won't be a pill
eventually it'll be a plug it'll be I
think it'll be like a a you know how you
know how the uh Apple laptop chargers
work they're magnets and it just clicks
in it doesn't actually like interlock it
just snaps that's what it's going to be
for the neuralink there's going to be
thin copper cables that go into your uh
I think that's what they're doing it
goes on your like sarabellum or whatever
and uh you'll have like a little metal
pad and you'll just take a little magnet
thing it go it'll stick right to it and
then you'll well elon's looking for
people right now if they want to sign up
to volunteer because FDA has approved
human trials where the robot he built
will cut open your skull and thread the
implant into your brain go for that this
is this is for people who are blf
paralyzed I'm totally fine with that but
the problem is we know where it goes and
you're going to have some 60-year-old
Millennial woman being like I just don't
have any friends anymore and I'm so
ladly and they're going to be like would
you like to be 20 again and go partying
back on the north side of Chicago plug
on in baby and sit in the pot and we'll
pump you full of bugs I would choose a
different thing I would be like the head
of the doj and
go all the you choose to live in the
reality where you get Justice and you
you're locked in the of the is
arrested I think that's the thing though
we have like one of the the the battles
for making to like reinvesting in
culture and reinvigorating culture is to
make it so that life outside the Pod is
better and worthy even when things are
hard it is more desirable to be there
because I think about you know you know
if you can go into the pot I guess you
could see all your loved ones whatever
else but they're not real like you have
to want the reality enough even with the
bad parts of it and I think we have
gener we have Generations that are being
trained to numb themselves and avoid
things always which makes the neural
sort of an inevitable reality because
it's the ultimate numbing it takes you
out of who you are Co lockdowns
accelerated like the divorce between
people who hate reality like nature
right and you saw a lot of people stay
in their homes I know people who had
young kids who did not leave their home
for five to six months right and they
could get their groceries delivered they
could be safe somehow they still got
coid in the apartments that's another
story but like their their identities
meant more to them online so their
digital identities took over their
physical identities which is why
metaverse is going to take over which is
why it's hilarious the other day when
we're sharing that image of that person
who had their Avatar as the girl but
Sydney whatever the name was right but
in real life it's just a trans person
there was a guy who's like a 50-year-old
dude right with a ponytail we've talked
about it's the movie surrogates you've
seen it no yeah yeah uh it's a world
where everyone sits in a pod and they
have a robot version of themselves go
out and work it's safer and there's like
this hot chick making out the guy some
there's an accident that happens and so
they try and track down the owner of the
of the surrogate and they find a 500 PB
morbidly obese man in a pod also dead
cuz some crazy thing happened but the
point is they were like oh that hot
chick you're making out with 500 lb
morbid Leo bees man that's like only
fans right now and there's guys
messaging women who who's or the
messages are coming from dudes and like
wherever they're from you know Idaho yo
the crazy thing is people don't care on
Instagram you have a whole bunch of AI
generated accounts and they say they are
and it's crazy people are commenting
like you're so beautiful I'm like it
says AI generated person they don't care
they don't care but there's no risk
telling AI you're beautiful right
there's no risk in doing that not going
out and having to meet a and say hey I
think you're pretty I'd love to take you
to dinner look have you ever played a
video game with cheat codes Game Genie
it gets boring yeah so so what happens
is typically the way you do it is you
play the game you beat it once you're
done then you play with cheat codes for
fun to explore the game but after a
while you're like I can do whatever I
want whatever I want I'm I'm over it I'm
bored this is what metaverse is going to
be like if unless people choose to enter
simulated realities with rules and
limits otherwise they'll get bored real
quick which is the end goal of Communism
to make people uh feel like they're the
god it's a false like reality of them
being the god whereas obviously though
that's not the case because the god
becomes the government and then they
destroy you but they want to make you
pretend that you're in charge and have
agency it makes me feel like we're on
the cusp of a lot of people waking up to
this I mean I I I I'm a girl so I like a
lot of relationship podcasts and a lot
of them you'll have girls calling in
talking about breakups and being like he
was just really controlling he wanted to
control me and it's like yes because
ultimately that is the same guy who will
pick to be in the noral link so that he
can control the entire environment
around him like we're all headed the
same direction we're going to jump to
this story and it's the perfect segue as
we're talking about living in a
simulation and the AI I present to you
this an urgent Manhunt is underway in
the New Jersey town of heleta for a
suspect in connection to the January 6
Capital attack Gregory Yetman evaded
arrest and fled into the woods near his
home uh see ABC has the latest from the
scene they actually interviewed his
neighbor whose name is is
stazzy bro welcome okay like like really
quick the big breaking news is a j sixer
is currently on the Run they're using
apcs dogs they're hunting him down but
the neighbor's name is stazzy and
everyone's just kind of sitting back
being like yo we're in a simulation even
better segue from the last topic is that
it's hell
meta that's the future when we're all in
the metaverse I'm thinking that that is
hell and that is meta wow dude that's
crazy it's a it's a simulation meta this
problem the problem with the simulation
is it's the the writers of the
simulation are so bad right like they're
on strike or something and and it's so
on the nose it's so on the nose Meta
Meta will be hell dude we should
copyright that right now that's amazing
so uh to come I mean so this is the big
story you know I don't want to get all
sci-fi and creepy and crazy with it this
is a guy another Ginger look at that
they're coming after persecuted yeah so
so apparently the story is that he had
already spoken with the FBI and they CLE
him and then something happened with USA
Today where they revealed more
information about him and then the feds
went to go serve an arrest warrant and
he ran into the woods guy who did
something three years ago is now a
breaking news Manhunt this makes no
sense to me yo and they're shutting
schools
down shelter shelter and place order W
well hold on we don't know this guy was
nonviolent I don't want to say that
right there were people there who Absol
absolutely violent and I don't know if
they have photos of of what he was doing
or whatever while he was there but maybe
he was this guy was in the National
guard at the time of j6 so that's kind
of crazy he brought a Humvees do you see
that what to j6 yeah there's a picture
of it he must have done
it wow no I think that's do you know him
from the group message you text him and
ask him to run through the woods
here no I mean I just like maybe he was
violent but at the same time it is crazy
to me that they are still arresting
people in connection to January 6th in
perpetuity forever and ever the end like
I skeptical that he is if he was such a
dangerous person that they would have
let it go this long I I'm sorry I I just
got to say this like there was something
that happened a couple years ago related
to Trump that was so insane like I was
it I'm like we're in a simulation like
how could this possibly be I can't
remember exactly what happened we talked
about on the show and everyone was
laughing like this is nuts now we're
literally talking about how weird all of
this is and we have a j sixer fing into
the woods whose neighbor's last name is
stazzy in the town of Hell meta
look this is what I'm saying about post
reality post reality is totality the
totality of events occurring both
digital and physical as a simulation
Burns but the simulation is not the
zeros and ones type of simulation I
believe the simulation is being
engineered by like corporate press and
governments no look look we're in the
final Seasons like you know the first
few seasons of Simpsons were just
awesome like the first nine and then
after that it's just been like a
downward spiral of like they're not
going to let the show end all the good
writers left right I I think this is
where we're at and what we're getting is
they're just they have no creat anymore
so they're like it's a guy whose
neighbor is the stazzy or something well
we can't do that her name is stazzy oh
that's good I like that do that it's
like an SNL sketch it's ridiculous or
maybe they're exhibitionists and they
just want to be seen I don't know man
like this is crazy stuff we say
simulation but the reality is I'm sure a
lot of Christians are just like this is
God's Universe like you're starting to
see it you know what I mean well that's
how I feel I think we're in base reality
God's reality and that people are
engineering this false reality on top of
us not to say that this guy running
around is but the way these things are
like hel meta or or you know stazzy and
any other thing that's been happening
the past year just seems so fake like
they're trying to make us buy into this
aggressively unreal reality not to say
this isn't happening there's a lot of
horrible things happening in the world
it'd be funny if we're actually already
in the pods eating the bugs and they're
just like playing and toying with us as
we're strapped in and we're just like
what this is life we're in base reality
and then pans out to Bas reality we're
already in the PT with tubes in our
throats we're just extras in a Black
Mirror episode don't know it yeah that
was another another idea had a while
back of like what if what if why here's
my argument for why we are all
NPCs when the NPCs don't know that
they're NPCs and the people who are
playing the game know they're playing
the game so if you aren't aware that
you're an external you you're outside
system playing the game then you're the
NPC and we're sitting here talking and
we're basically three it's three dog
right that was the guy from uh uh uh uh
fallout the radio host so when you're
playing Fallout it's a post-apocalyptic
Wasteland you turn the radio on and he's
talking right and that's it that's basic
you're the player you're playing the
game and we're the background noise to
facilitate your your our vo is in a
wasteland great yeah like I I would have
to assume that like this is this is
Trump's game you know Trump is the Trump
is like some 15-year-old playing the
video game of like it's called like
Earth right and he's he's that's his
character and he's playing and he's like
you know he's it's is nearing the the
end of the game or whatever and we're
just anel characters I like to think not
but it does feel like that sometimes for
sure that doesn't matter if it does or
doesn't I guess your life is your life
would it change how you act that's my
question it wouldn't for me I would
still act with the moral code I Believe
In You know despite yeah You' go crazy I
do what I want and you wouldn't know if
you weren't doing what you want because
apparently we're all in the pods anyway
no I'm just kidding so does this guy
have charges brought against him they
were serving an a West an arrest warrant
is my his last his last name is yet man
what this is what I'm seeing from they
Haven caught him yet they haven't caught
they haven't caught him yet man the New
York Times says that he was uh he had
been interviewed by the FBI for his
participation in the riot and and that
he was believed to have uh fired a large
canister of Pepper Sprite at protesters
and the police so this guy was on no
one's side it's just you with a haircut
that's
my you all know each other right from
the ginger j6 sub subreddit what if the
aliens are actually just like uh game
moderators and the reason they can defy
physics is because their vehicles are
outside of the game for the for the
purpose of facilitating the simulation
right we can't see them the way the ants
aren't perceiving us I like yo this I I
I'm just I'm flabbergast in reading the
story because it looks like it's like
when a when a game writer has his kid
write up a a quest MH you know it's a
guy who who's working for World of
Warcraft has his 11-year-old son write
up a quest for him they'll put in the
game and they'll put it in because it's
funny and he can if if when I was a a
professor of creative writing let's say
and a student came to me with a like
this I would say maybe this is like
unless it's a satire maybe this is all
two on the nose cuz every name is
ridiculous hell meta like we're just
we're not reaching that far yet man like
come on this is like a vaget rather you
know maybe they're using vaget stories I
don't know you know I just found out
recently just a little side note on the
post reality stuff that vag's brother
invented seeding clouds w wow dude
silver ey died seaing that was him yeah
yeah what a fun family yeah just just
all kinds of stuff for the simulation
people out there maybe it's like a
Truman Show mhm you know I wonder who
Truman would
be well maybe it's Trump or maybe it's
just shift you know from from all of
usbe Truman is in heleta and that's how
they're keeping him inside because
they're like hey there's a man Hound to
go outside right now we got to change
the sets real charge our little birds
everyone go inside for it' be funny if
Trump is like like Earth as a Truman
Show we're we're all ancillary
characters that don't matter but the
aliens watch Trump all day and they're
like they love him I mean who doesn't
love watching Trump he's entertainment
there's several seasons in so it's
getting really off the rails they don't
know do but there is real world data to
support this theory in terms of uh
Donald Trump's Uncle having the Tesla
stuff either Trump is a time traveler or
he or or he knows the aliens wait so is
is yay just like a Side Story is it like
a different he like a fun
character is Roy right like okay they
they introduce a random character to
boost the ratings and then he's gone a
season later true oh I was thinking like
all the dimensions kind of merged in the
past few years and yay is another
protagonist From Another Dimension
like and him and did meet up for a bit
but they're like we're too crazy to do
this together Marvel and DC kind of yeah
I would say kany is close to The Truman
Show though because Truman did break
somewhere towards the end of the show
it's it's Kanye you know what I think is
funny I was watching the I was watching
clips from The Truman Show because
there's a meme where it's uh he's Truman
is arguing with his wife and then she's
like what COC yeah and he's like who are
you talking to but that wouldn't be
weird to them because she would have
been doing that his whole life yeah it
would been a normal social thing to be
like look at product it's a great
product you'd be like yep that's what
people do and we're all used to it now
because of influencer culture he'd be
doing the same thing hey I'm just on my
Instagram stories like putting my kids
to bed and I thought I'd tell you about
this thing just randomly because I'm
definitely getting sponsored to do it
I'm sorry I got to do it like as much as
I love the daily wire guys and I think
they're doing such great work I just got
to point out one thing I could never do
is because if you've watched their shows
you know exactly what they do they'll
say something like I got to tell you
when I learned about how great VI
ramaswami did at that debate I was so
happy to hear it as happy as I was to
try spin drift an excellent drink where
and I'm just like I know it's seamless
and it's probably the better way to do
an ad read but I just I could never do
that yeah yeah it's uh kind of like how
I feel on on X these days when I see
something about for instance it was it
was on Scott Adams uh page and it was
about the 3D printed suicide pods with
an ad right below it for let's say a a
device for pleasure for women uh and I
was just like that is so and it's and it
was like a lady waving goodbye in the
Pod smiling next to this ad saying like
double the pleasure it's like this is
just a horrible I got I got to give a
shout out to Michael nolles I guess he's
sold out of like four months worth of
cigars yeah wow and yeah now I'm like
well now I got to buy I don't smoke but
like got to support the parallel economy
man we've got Jeremy soap downstairs
what is is that a thing I don't is there
soap now yeah there was I saw that like
soap and deodorant and I'm like what I
didn't know that existed I was just
waiting for him with like dark chocolate
but instead he was like on to the next
product give it time like there's going
to be two realities in 50 years there's
going to be the people who live in the
pods and eat the bugs outside you're
going to go to Jeremy's which is like
you go inside it's a superstore
warehouse that has every product sign up
for Jeremy's membership and they got
everything they got beef they got Pork
yeah it's basically Costco but it'll be
called Jeremy yeah we'll get there I
would do ad reads for fun products like
not real ones like ejection seats and
helicopters like a
whole oh what a beautiful image but it
is interesting this idea that like
people are trying to read uh meaning or
value like I think people feel so lost
in everything that's happening they're
trying to find Clues like this idea that
it's heleta like is this the sign are we
looking for something and I think that
is again this craving for direction in
life that people just don't have we're
going to get we're going to get serious
guys we're going to bring it back to the
real world gu crazy story of New York
here we go vigilante gunman nabbed for
shooting at homeless would be robber in
New York City subway station I want you
to analyze that headline real quick
vigilante G someone read read read it
for me vigilante gunman nabbed for
shooting at homeless would be robber in
NYC subway station and what did you
notice in that headline oh well the
wouldbe the would be because uh the
story could also be homeless man throws
woman in front of train yeah instead
it's a vigilante nabbed I love they they
arrested the guy I don't think it's wise
to shoot in a Subway don't get me wrong
but it is crazy that we are getting to
this point we've warned about it a
homeless guy was mugging a woman and
trying to steal her stuff this guy sh
shouted out fired a what he called a
warning shot but I'm not I'm not a fan
of warning shots in subways I don't
think that makes sense and and and
stopped it right the point is obviously
don't shoot in crowded places like that
because you don't know what's where that
bol's going to go and you don't what
damage you're going to cause there
there's a lot of stuff down there but
more importantly it's gotten to the
point where people have started
illegally in New York City carrying guns
and they're not criminals and they're
not bad guys they're doing it because
they're scared for their safety and now
we've got the return of subway
vigilantism M you mean they're playing
by the same rules as the criminals
that's right uh-huh y I can't think of a
major city that's like Pro 2A that has a
serious homeless population but I mean
the obvious answer is if if you had a
large homeless population but everyone
in the community including the homeless
world where people carried guns it would
be very different Nashville maybe I
guess I don't really know I don't know I
it's hard for me to I want to say yes I
feel like well because it's in Tennessee
I might think yes I don't know what
Nashville's particular LA but it's that
there was pretty clean I was there maybe
like three months ago oh there's parts
that definitely have a homeless problem
but it's not like an aggressive problem
like I I've seen in parts of and if you
were in I mean like all of the cities
where you know you know crime is really
rampid especially with being perpetrated
by homeless people like I think of San
Francisco you can't carry a gun in San
Francisco what you talking about so in
some ways wouldn't it behoove someone in
the New York State Senate to say hey
maybe we should change the gun laws in
New York so people can carry to deter
crime instead they they'll never don't
like the don't they have a robot police
officer down there that now
patrolling the the subway oh just
imagine what that's going to be like you
know a guy comes up to you stop it a guy
comes up to you and he's like punching
you in the face and trying to grab your
purse and then the robot goes criminal
you are breaking the law please stop
stop and we finally found something more
useless than gun loss it's going to be
funny when the robot the robot will just
go whoop whoop whoop right while you're
while this guy's mercilessly beating a
woman someone will just push the robot
in front of a train yes I'm I'm afraid
to give them ideas but maybe like a Ador
opens with an arm to apprehend and then
put them inside shoot tasers and
hopefully hits the right person big
robot you know it's like a candy it's
like a giant candy corn it's like glass
so you can see fires a bag and then
seals them in like we should stop giving
them ideas though for sure cuz they will
do that but it's interesting they won't
send police down there they'll just send
the robot here's what I love I love the
combination of of future automated
dystopia along with the economic
collapse dystopia cuz it results in
homeless people destroying robots in San
Francisco yes they're just flipping the
machines over and smashing them and
stealing food out of them kicking the
robot dog yeah that's that's kind of a
cool feature I don't know I don't know
what am I supposed to say about this
they've got robots driving around San
Francisco s San Fran delivering food and
Terri just flip them over and then steal
the food and leave and there's like what
are they going to do about it there's no
humans this is the Natural Evolution of
Battle Bots it is in the subway does
look like a battle bot actually yeah
maybe they need to work on the
Transformer suit then and like a person
should be inside again stop giving them
ideas please I want to go straight to
RoboCop where they have the one that
malfunctions talking about RoboCop and
Ai and IR suits I think what we should
be really scared about is the Amazon
stores where you can walk in and you
don't need you just grab whatever you
want and walk out it automatically
charges you that is the private sector
basis for what will become horrifying
Robo law enforcement yeah you think it's
bad now it's like oh who cares you walk
in grab your you know milk bread and
eggs and walk out it's convenient what
do you think it's going to be like when
those things are everywhere you go
everywhere you jaywalk you get a ticket
in the mail yeah y that's crazy that's
crazy to me and also how the way you
started this by looking at the title
like the the way they Bend reality is
what's terrifying to me right like they
could have written this headline so many
different ways you know and like that
that does frame people's perception
clearly like the uh the other day when
the guy was killed in uh California at
the protest you know he died in the
street and then he was a dead guy or
whatever they made it sound like he fell
or whatever elderly man falls and his
head dies right they frame these
realities that are so crazy this is that
right then people you know a lot of
people don't have the time to we talk
about it all the time right A lot of
people just read the post but this is
the same here's a headline for you
vigilante e gunman who saves woman's
life from attempted robbery arrested for
firing gun in Subway No it should just
be man arrested after defending self in
subway from no no he didn't defend
himself defending like someone else I
meting Penny again
I have no problem with the headline
saying he opened he fired a gun in in
the subway you should not do that that's
a problem for sure for sure I don't mind
that they identify him as someone who
shot a gun my problem is nabbed makes it
seem like he was the problem when there
is homeless person robbing someone on
the subway like man intervenes fires gun
during attempted robbery you know what I
mean like there are other ways to do it
except the first three words in this are
saying this is who you should be framing
as the villain it's a negative
connotation V vigilante gunman like the
bad people people with guns who are
defending themselves and defending
others I just want to say this is the
New York Post and they are famous for
one of the best headlines ever headless
body and topless bar yeah yeah wow
classic we'll bring that back because
it's way better whenever whatever's
happening right now we're almost there
again with this world that they're
creating and is this the same paper that
thought Nikki Haley won last night cuz
it wouldn't make sense with the way
perceive reality who won the debate
Nikki Haley and I was like I know she
didn't a New York Post alert not a New
York Post I'll have to look at it but I
got a news alert on my phone being like
who won last night's debate Nikki Haley
just in case you didn't no questions she
won sure wow wow and if you didn't if
you if you watched it you'd just be like
huh it's crazy they can't control
reality anymore two screens one mov is
anyone watching the debates though
because I think Trump's up like 50
points or something yeah you know who
won last night's debate Trump as per
usual yeah yeah we have more viewers yep
I'm concerned that he does get the
nomination and then he ends up getting
arrested he can't run maybe they go
after the 14th they say you can't run
who they going to put in last minute
they've had no air time no screen time
it's going to be an absolute mess well
Minnesota recently said that um they're
not keeping Trump off like they're not
goingon to during the primaries right
now cforia so the issue is this the
states do not have the right to
determine eligibility only the federal
government does which means any lawsuit
to remove Trump from the from the
federal elections could not be done at
the state level it needs to be done at
the federal level and the federal
government needs to make the
determination
and they already did with the
impeachment trial for which Trump was
acquitted so uh the way it's supposed to
work constitutionally is if a president
does something wrong they are impeached
and tried if convicted they are then
criminally potentially if they want to
pursue it then criminally indicted and
and and and tried again in this instance
uh uh Trump was acquitted wasn't even
wasn't even wasn't even uh uh uh
convicted in the impeachment tra he was
impeached but not removed y so it should
be done but they're going to do it
anyway because it's partisan I like the
Minnesota ruling because the judges said
there's no there's nothing in under
state law that says that we can say
someone can't participate in a primary
and then you know you guys have to
decide on the federal level if this is
if if you have the ability to take him
off from the general election I think it
is really good that our system is set up
where there are steps and there's power
at the state level and power at the
federal level because that's the only
way to keep it from being like we'll
Colorado said he can't be on there's the
Colorado ruling is not in but you know
this one state did something so now we
all have to obey it think it's good to
have the differentiation and I'm glad
that the Minnesota ruling came out first
sure I don't think Colorado matters as
much
but uh one state taking his name off and
that's going to spike the popular vote
count for him which could lead to Crazy
turmoil in this
country could like he could has anyone
won before with
Rens I don't know I'm assuming to a
certain degree maybe there's a whole
campaign right now to get to do a
writing campaign New Hampshire primary
because Biden didn't register to be on
the ticket because Biden and the DNC are
saying no New Hampshire's not going
first this year South Carolina is wait
wait wait Biden's not on the primary in
New Hampshire they Biden's gone he's not
running yeah well their whole thing is
it has to be South Carolina First this
has like been this is kind of
complicated but it's it's been a ploy
for a little while they want the the DNC
and the B and the bid Administration
want South Carolina to be the first
state in the nation to have their
primary because they're saying it's
better for diversity whatever else uh
Biden got wrecked in New Hampshire when
he ran last time but he won South
Carolina by 26 points so shortly after
he took office this became the campaign
and so because the DNC formally decided
that South Carolina's going first this
is not true for Republicans it's very
weird year um they are New Hampshire
says no we're going first South Carolina
says but the DNC said we're going first
and so Biden said well I'm I'm not going
to register to be on the ballot in New
Hampshire because South Carolina's going
first I mean it is a bizarre everyone
says that the right is fractured but I
think the right is is just a more of a
mosaic anyways there is obvious
disagreement whereas Democrats try to
operate like they're a monolith but they
are fracturing in so many different ways
I mean the Democrats in New Hampshire
are extremely upset about losing
potentially losing first in the nation
primary and there specific thing is
you're opening the door for Republicans
to spend more money here and convert
more voters it's very very weird I I
highly recommend looking into this it's
119 and I was told something was
supposed to happen today all the weird
conspiracy theorists were like 119 what
happens now I don't know the que thing I
don't know reverse you have an
announcement to make over there 119 is
when Trump won in
2016 interesting yeah wasn't it I don't
know wasn't that the day that he won the
election 2016 I'm not sure maybe
something did happen we don't know yet
we've been sucked into a well we're busy
we're podcasting we don't even know
somebody let us know this breaking news
did someone turn on the Large Hadron
Collider today have we been sucked into
the sphere of strangeness once again
like we keep right it it was the
election was November 8th and it went
into November 9th and concluded with
Trump winning on November 9th there's
always a q Theory coming out we were
talking about downstairs it's this was
not a theory numy oh the world's going
to end in five years then five years
happens and the Cults or Jesus is coming
back and then the que is old Trump is
still president wait you know about the
red
heer I think I watched your podcast in
this one yeah yeah there was a Jerusalem
Post there was a forward.com article and
they were just like the red has been
born and that signifies the coming of
the Messiah or something like that I
don't know anything about it I just read
some article and that was a month before
the Hamas attack yeah yeah but what if
they just clone some thing and died
they're trying to I know they're
engineering the end times yes but they
can't so so people are actually trying
to genetically engineer the red heer but
it has to have no it's not they many
these people believe they're supposed to
bring about the prophecy not wait for it
right accelerate it but no but I I
reject this this the the the the the
idea that prophecy only ever was
something to wait for is made up by made
up these are people who are like if it
says this must be done it's a to-do list
not a wait for list but the problem is
they can't do it even when they
selectively breed the the heers the cows
it ends up with blemishes and so they're
trying and it's been it's been what like
thousands of years or whatever they've
not been able to do it but why don't
they invent some like skincare for it
and see if they can it's got to be
naturally because these people genuinely
believe that you have to breed it
they're not trying to convince a
carnival right they're trying to find
something that they believe is
signifying the coming of the Messiah so
it was reported in September that they
did and now they have to wait for it to
get a little older and then they're
going to check it for blemishes and this
happens a lot and then they say ah there
it is it's got a Mark it's not it's not
a pure red heer and but if it's not it
has to be sacrificed and the fear is if
someone claims that this is a pure red
heer again not an expert I read one
article then they will have to sacrifice
this for the start of the Third Temple
or whatever which will put them at odds
with Islam or something so I don't know
enough about it all I know is a lot of
people who you don't have to believe
what they believe to be worried about a
bunch of people who yeah fighting and
causing problems because they might
believe it's like waiting on the on the
next Dal Lama remember that one kid they
they believe there the next one and then
didn't China kidnap him right China
doesn't know and then they also declared
their own doll Lama so it's impossible
to say what happened to the first one
they well it's the one that China thinks
is right though you can't can't question
it yeah it's crazy I just want to know
what the red heer tastes like is that a
good thing I don't know I think they
just sacrifice and bleed it out right
yeah that's according to like the uh the
kosher laws I'm pretty sure as well do
you feel like this is good
representation for gingers that we're
trying to breed more red
haers he told me earlier name of his new
podcast this is there there's enough of
us there's enough of us all right we've
been having too much fun let's get
really dark with it this is a this is a
really really big story from uh earlier
today Israel demands action after
journalists reportedly joined Hamas
Massacre AP CNN Reuters and the New York
Times They had reporters this is a an
investigative I'm sorry this is the uh
here we go honest reporting is a i gu an
NGO that it it pushes back on articles
that it says are posting fake news about
Israel and uh they have some photos
taken by Hassan
asaya at the conflict and there are
serious questions any editor should have
asked about these photos excuse me good
sir uh uh reporter that we are paying
how did you get this photo Hamas is
allowing you to film their operations
how did you know to film in these
locations were you with Hamas what did
they tell you now there's serious real
There's real questions would we rather
have the the photos or not my concern is
if these quote unquote reporters are
embedded with Hamas there's a photo they
actually have a photo of one of the guys
with one of the Hamas leaders holy yeah
like they look like friends and so it
would seem the images and photos that
came out were intentionally released by
Hamas to control the narrative and if
these news organizations paid these
individuals they were directly funding
Hamas yeah I'm not surprised cuz these
are the same corporate corporate press
people who are funding BLM and basically
embeded with them and helping burn down
and they have young progressives on
staff who would think this is Justified
I mean we saw this in the US there's no
reason to think it's not happening in
the newsrooms everywhere when I saw this
story today I I thought of I forget his
full name but I think the last name was
Sullivan and he was the guy at j6 who
was selling his footage uh from inside
the capital and it was on CNN yeah he
made a bunch of money and then like day
after something like that he's on video
waving the knife like doing like
instigating literal m bad stuff you know
so I I see you know this is just the
next step for these people this is what
they do but I would like to know who
they are like uh to what degree did they
partake in this I do want to see the
photos and then I want to be able to
judge for myself uh but like are they
Freelancers did they know the
publication beforehand do we know that
are they are they retainer Freelancers
right did the New York Times AP CNN as
organizations know the attack was going
to happen I got to be honest I think
it's possible totally they're claiming
they don't they're saying we had no idea
this was going to happen well they have
to say that but look what does it mean
for an organization to say we didn't
know does that mean an editor didn't
know it's entirely possible one of these
guys contacted their you know buyer
whatever and said look there's going to
be a major military action on the 7th I
can get you the photos you know here's
how much I want negotiated the question
that we that needs to be asked the
deeper investigation is how quickly were
these photos released because if they
were released instantly that means a
pre-existing relationship was in play
and these guys are likely on some kind
of retainer or payroll or at the very
least sent an email saying check out
these photos do you want to buy them and
they immediately just said yes without
question here's a photo Palestinian
Palestinian militants from Gaza Strip
run the Gate of uh uh kibutz kafar Aza
on
Saturday uh uh from run run by the gate
so is this a photo of them appear
appearing to try and get
in
could this
reporter have warned someone they were
about to go and and kill a bunch of
civilians is it the duty of the reporter
to do so I mean these are serious moral
questions yes and uh unless he's
ideologically aligned with Hamas in
which case he is a propaganda mouthpiece
of Hamas that is being paid by the
American corporate press it's one thing
to embed yourself with a thing and and
and report on it but it's another thing
to I think you have it's e ethically you
must say something if you you know
that's going to happen yeah doesn't
matter how embedded you are that's
ridiculous the but like when that
picture of him kissing the kissing
picture like is that from he's being
kissed October 6 like it when is that
picture even from it matters it could be
from years ago but uh I mean only
matters because Hamas has spent a lot of
time trying to embed themselves in the
good graces of progressives in America I
mean what was the line from you know I
think it was a 2019 interview where he
was saying you know equating basically
the Hamas and their actions to BM and
George right and he used those words
because he knows that there is an
emotional reaction on the American left
this is a longstanding uh goal of Hamas
in my observational understanding of it
that they want the American left
journalism class to be sympathetic to
them totally and so it wouldn't be
surprising me if a journalist has a
positive relationship with both uh a
western outlet and Hamas and Hamas was
like yeah come here let's do it and I
don't know if that journalist is
objective enough to understand what they
are consenting to or what they are Ena
with their what media Outlet was it that
said they were bombed by Israel years
ago but it turns out they were in the
headquarters of Hamas that that time do
you remember that story there it was a
there was a media center right that it
was claimed this is just where reporters
are and then it came out that Hamas used
the subev for weapons and stuff yes yeah
cuz that's what they do yeah and we all
do it like this country's got bad bad
press or working with our bad agents all
the time you know I do think it's funny
cuz like the US has blown up killed a
bunch of people at weddings in Pakistan
and things like that you know what I
mean exactly come on so you know I I
just I just can't stand the uh the
hypocrisy more importantly I mean look
the these these corporate corporate news
organizations they're evil they are big
faceless corporations the only thing
that editor was thinking was I can't get
in trouble but we get these photos out
it's big how much do you want they
didn't even stop to say how did you get
these photos cuz look man if it turns
out that you're working with these guys
we can't give you any money for this
it's even worse than if he says okay you
can take them for free because that
means you are are putting out the
propaganda they want released and I
think you know a lot of people say why
would they want that that released Shing
of the horrible things they're doing you
know they filmed themselves doing
horrible things they published this
footage they wanted to destroy the
Abraham Accords and shift negotiating
power back to to Palestine by saying hey
look we're crazy and Biden gave him $100
million yep yeah it's crazy I would ad
recommend anyone who cares about what's
going on behind the scenes at corporate
media places to watch the best movie
network and it goes through I'm mad as
all I'm not going to take it anymore
that's it you know and how they exploit
uh violence Madness you know and what
what they do for the clicks for the
views it's one of my favorite movies one
of the best written movies with the best
dialogue ever but I think that movie
even though I came out in probably 70s
or 80s it is just as uh relevant today
as it was then yeah I I think it's
unsurprising that this is happening I am
curious what the response would be from
AP or Reuters whoever put out the photos
because ultimately they control the news
so even if they put out a statement they
can bury it as fast as anything else did
CNN fired the guy did they say what
capacity he work with them uh well let's
let's read this from the messenger they
say uh CNN other organizations blah blah
blah blah blah and uh let's see in a
statement posted act the Israeli Prime
Minister said this okay come on come on
CNN told is Outlet wet that it had
severed ties with Esa in the wake of the
honest reporting investigation saying we
are aware of the article and photo
concerning Hassan Esa a freelance photo
journalist who has worked with a number
of international and Israeli Outlets CNN
wrote in a statement oh yeah while we
have not at this time found reason to
doubt the journalistic accuracy of the
work he's done for us we have decided to
suspend all ties with him the network
added that kind of sounds like they're
saying holy crap we're in trouble cut
cut ties with him and and dismiss it
yeah because if if it really was a
nothing they would say look it's a
freelancer we've worked with in the past
we have no comment mhm mhm that's what I
was thinking is that he's this guy is
probably not like a direct employee of
CNN it's probably not that so he's a
freelancer so are the news companies
just the middleman and then maybe
someone's calling and saying hey we got
someone over there right maybe doesn't
matter
because you can't legally give material
support to a terrorist organization so
the questions that are arising with with
this is look this is not an instance
where photos emerged of someone in the
music festival who had been there and
said look I was here in Israel I was
filming this is a guy who's Palestinian
in Gaza who has photos from inside
Israel meaning he breached the barriers
with he that like he's with the guy the
the bigger question is did these media
organizations pay Hamas for the
propaganda material Hamas wanted
released MH yeah I think that's a big
problem this I think this ethically is
just a giant nightmare you know uh and
it reminds me of this weird story about
this there's this journalist from back
in the day who's in the new journalism
movement wrote a lot of great stories
and then in his old years uh he he wrote
a story about a guy with a motel who was
a Voyer looking at the people who were
in his hotel rooms and then he embedded
himself with that person and like me
reading that I'm like ethically you
should be warning everybody about this
but instead he's like cozying up to this
guy looking through the pee Pooles mhm
the the the AP claims the first pictures
they received show they were taken more
than an hour after the attacks began no
AP staff were at the border uh at the
time of the attacks nor did any AP staff
were cross the border at that time that
does not mean this guy was not there and
people are posting a video showing one
of these reporters holding a grenade or
something like this that's what's what's
being reported on X and uh yo Israel is
saying these these journalists are going
to be treated as terrorists that's crazy
is Lion now says he fears for his life
those who stood quote as Idol bystanders
while children were slaughtered are no
different than terrorists and should be
treated as such
that's crazy man see this is where it
gets interesting I don't like do if this
guy's a legitimate journalist and he's
not with Hamas do we want these photos
we want to see what they're doing yes
unfortunately but yes but the question
is is he actually aligned with them and
our news organization paying a guy and
providing material support to the
propaganda wing of Hamas that's the
problem I got to be honest I don't think
anyone operates in Gaza without the
approval of Hamas I don't think this guy
could be a journalist without them like
a pal journalist in Gaza they know who
he is they have to he's selling photos
to the AP being played
internationally I there's there's no
circumstance in my mind where Hamas is
like n you're fine do whatever you want
no they probably said here's what he
expect from you here's what you have to
do and he says you got it well that's
what I'm saying I don't think the he's
not cn's guy right this guy does work
for someone someone is paying his bills
to be there live there and exist there
and that's the question I want to have
answered is this guy part of Hamas is he
part of intelligence agency like how do
you get training to hang out with Hamas
and not get shot right you have to buddy
buddy this isly this is the question
picture of him getting kissed I mean
come on yeah right there that's crazy
and he's smiling and he's taking the
selfie yeah so it's not like they F they
staged the photo he was like Hey I'm gon
to get a picture with me and this guy
who's kissing me that's crazy I mean but
if he's Palestinian it would be curious
to hear what his personal view on Hamas
is anyways right I mean people in in
Palestine have a long and complicated
relationship with Hamas because Hamas
used to provide Social Services I mean
there was there was Hamas pre what we
know it it day it's not that I'm
justifying hamas's existence but uh as a
Palestinian journalist maybe you view it
differently I don't know or maybe if he
truly was embedded and he truly is an
investigative journalist that's the role
he was playing you know or maybe that's
the story he's going to tell you either
way it's ridiculous but if he is
Palestinian right then he's subject to
hamas's whims yeah oh yeah I mean this
is this is propaganda for them well and
also like if he's just like I'm a nice
journalist and I want to do a good job
and Hamas maybe I take your picture and
they know that he's ultimately going to
give the photos to CNN or to any kind of
Western Outlet there's a chance that
they're like yes of course we'll treat
you really nicely come on in because
again they ultimately you know there's
this question of material support So
Hamas may not be paying him but they do
want him to circulate images of them
Hamas has not been quiet about the fact
that they want public attention imagine
what would have happened if Hamas didn't
film any of what happened on October 7th
right there would be limited video from
security cameras and dash cams and some
people film but a lot of the most
gruesome stuff we've seen they filmed
themselves mhm like killing civilians in
cars and stuff like that right they
wanted people to see what they were
doing yeah for sure that's messed up man
which is why they're ping around with
the press as well or is the Press look
man when you go to these protests in the
far left these quote unquote journalists
wearing press badges they're they're
activists they're antia absolutely but
you of have to look at like Tik Tok
right like Tik Tok has tons of V video
footage that's coming out on the ground
in Palestine right now of people in
Palestine saying you know Israel is
making us walk to the southern part of
the state or you know there is a counter
effort and so Hamas saying and this is
just off the cuff my opinion about it
but like Hamas saying yes we are willing
to show what we're doing kind of tells
the citizens yes you should also be
recording and trying to distribute
what's happening here as much as
possible and it makes the narrative more
complicated which is ultimately what
Hamas really wants and I just also want
to stress that every government is doing
this at the same time to varying degrees
right but like gadoo is about to show
some film
fight broke out saw no yeah she had a
screening and a fight broke out dressed
up as Wonder Woman or she wasn't at the
fight but a fight broke out outside the
1984 outfit not as good yeah not as good
not as good but everyone's got
propagandist on their payroll you know
and it it's we should all be very aware
of that no matter if it's this
government in America these guys Hamas
the IDF they all got it and uh just I
would be we call it would we call it
propaganda if it was something everyone
agreed
with like let's say that um
we'd call it successful propaganda well
like let's say that everyone in this
country absolutely agrees with the right
to wear shoes and then someone makes a
documentary explaining why it's
important to wear shoes we wouldn't call
it propaganda we'd call it a documentary
right it's propaganda when you have
competing ideological interests fighting
with each other and as IDE ideologies
fracture United States everything turns
into propaganda yeah so we make
infringed my view of it is it is a uh
it's a journey of you know Lauren goes
through meeting people and and exploring
the ideas of gun control and then
factually reporting on the importance of
keeping and bearing arms what the
founding fathers meant and we think we
are correct in what we're saying and how
we're saying it and then people who hate
guns are going to say it's propaganda
right in some respects though to your
shoe example propaganda would include it
wouldn't just be like oh shoes are good
they protect your feet it be like and
they make you stronger and better and
they ultimately support every single
aspect of our economy I mean propag has
to do with an overwhelming lobbying for
something I disagree infringed ends with
Lauren saying buy a gun while you still
can or something that affs
but it's it's if you made a documentary
you said the founding fathers intended
people to keep in bare arms because in
order to form a militia to fight a for
foreign or domestic threat the populace
would need to be armed and prepared to
use weapons the left will say that's a
lie that's not true that's propaganda
the founding fathers expected regulated
militias that they were in control of to
be doing this this is a right-wing
propaganda lie that's my point we call
our stuff news and information we call
the the counterpoints and and and we
would view as lies as propaganda and
then the other people do the same thing
I don't think everyone calls everything
to disagree with like if you watch Forks
Over Knives right there just like gave
birth to a huge wave of veganism in at
least in my generation uh I wouldn't
call it propaganda it's just alternative
information right it's not right right
so if your argument is that we are
honest people and they're not then okay
I don't really have an argument other
them saying like propaganda tends to be
uh
over celebratory of the thing that it's
trying to push or information sure but
it's not over over different points of
view doesn't inherently have to be
propaganda if an activist organization
that was
pro-abortion made a bunch of uh uh made
a documentary that excluded all of the
arguments of the pro-life side we'd call
that
propaganda typically you would because
it's not balanced I mean that would also
be true of like any written thing where
it's just like here's our side over and
over again and that's my point so when
we make infringed is it balanced we're
advocating for buying guns I think it is
important that everyone does train and
exercise their rights keep your arms the
founding fathers did intend these things
for these reasons people did own
warships back in the day private
companies own nuclear weapons these are
all true today and the left would say
it's propaganda it's proun propaganda
yeah so what my point is we have these
disperate ideologies popping up and no
unified ideology everything is turning
into you know like ideological attacks
on everybody else yeah I mean ultimately
it changes why people are motivated to
create anything right if you
think I hard get back to my example of
always being This American Life when
This American Life you know way back in
the day when it would come out they do
these thematic episodes and you'd get
kind of weird unusual stories but
ultimately if you have a political
objective or you have a specific point
you're trying to make it changes the T
the type of content you're creating it's
kind of like how serial speaking of NPR
uh you know that that it turned when
they first aired it it was this huge
phenomenon narrative about that guy who
they thought was wrongfully accused and
then retrospect it kind of sounds like
it was just propaganda to make him sound
more innocent because now it sounds like
the story isn't what they said it was
and that's because of what they left out
you know the omissions to all the the
larger parts of that narrative we're
going to go to Super Chat so if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
head over to
timcast.net check out the infringed
documentary by Lauren Southern just
dropped this week it's a it's a great
film and we're going to be pushing it
pretty heavily throughout the next
couple weeks for sure and uh we'll read
some super chats RJ McDougle Heim with
the first Super Chat saying yo yo
congratulations Alva turkey says who are
they more afraid of trump or VI Trump
trump right now VI though they're
they're probably right now saying like
Okay Trump's are immediate threat I'm
like you got to keep an eye on this guy
cuz he's he's he's doing this thing
Trump's doing this is what I said like
if you think that any other candidate
after Trump's going to be treated any
differently than Trump you haven't been
paying attention these are the tactics
they're going to use Forever and Ever
from here on out yep fatty Tang says FCC
voting on Biden's internet plan next
week it gives the administrative State
effective control of all internet
services and infrastructure oh
boy I'm excited for that what a time to
be alive just gives me a headache okay
okay Bitner tun say says howdy viewer
since 2020 your work inspired me to
enter the culture Arena and launch my
own cartoon profile on AXS please shout
out at Bitner Tunes nice shout out waful
Sensei says well look at that member for
30 months VI will be president in
2028 I could see that be cool I think we
need more talented people I like seeing
you know vake Thrive I like seeing
Talent rise the top MH hey waffle he's
in one of my group chats all right he's
a nice guy that's awesome yeah elf tree
hug says we need to vote for people that
love this country and want to make it
work when things become too polarized
they stop respecting the systems in
place and the systems break down I.E
branches of government the Constitution
uh you know it yep Matt Hudson says I
tried to be first but I failed my name
is Matt Hudson and I a worldclass non-qm
loan processor available to grow your
company hire me I'm not a communist also
I love Mastiffs I don't know what a loan
processor does process
I would assume that that doesn't
necessarily mean it's the only thing
they do and we don't need loans we have
uh we have we have no
need glad a communist though yeah glad
that that's good that's that's a good
one communist one less communist Michael
and jelli says brace ban struck down
along with frame and receiver rule but
government can still appeal and fight it
keep spreading the message shall not be
infringed my also my understanding is
too is the rule still uh in effect
pending the appeal so yes so they they
basically extended um I just listen to a
podcast this the morning uh they
extended the um you don't have to be a
part of these two groups that how are
representing people you now it's
everyone everyone everywhere it used to
be two lawsuits were brought and if you
were a member of these two companies or
you were in their services you were
shielded under the orisinal ruling it
went back and forth now they extended it
to everyone but my understanding is you
like we're still waiting for a final
ruling but right right right in the
meantime yeah okay chief opof says today
I subscribe to today I subscribed to
Ian's Channel and I got a timcast
membership Tim we've had plenty of
one-way arguments over the years since
occupi but I've always truly appreciated
what you do I'm happy to get a
membership thank you very much good sir
y'all should become members and hang out
on the Discord because they're they're
also doing an infringed viewing party
that's awesome super cool yeah hang out
with your friends and watch a movie and
eat popcorn just as the way it was
supposed to be Discord is incredible
they do so much stuff yeah they're
incredible Cal Martin says just watched
infringed great documentary and
encourage anyone fans of the Second
Amendment or not to watch it I think
it's the kind of thing you want your
family members who are not 2A to watch
with you and uh you can tell right it's
like it's a you know it talks about gun
control stuff and let's let's watch it
and then you know there you go talks
about democide when all these
governments fascists Nazis Etc were were
Communists were killing their own people
yeah yeah man I'm gonna send a copy to
David hog he should watch it yes he
should watch it sparkart says off topic
how do you think zalinski is going to
explain to the as of Battalion that
Israel is now getting their funds and
now they're asking for loans they will
need to pay back with interest
o uh oh man the the simulation just
that's just the writing is wild and
sometimes yeah that one's that one
that's pretty good that's really good
man J de says unbeatable ticket hear me
out Patrick Bet David Tucker Carlson I
Can Dream unfortunately Patrick could he
was not born in the United States yeah
he cannot be
president change that I think too many
media personalities on one ticket might
not work for the voters like voters do
want to see someone they they feel more
Rel to right right someone they've
already voted for once and they did a
good job they have a history of being in
government at least doing some positive
things yeah Ben Hixon says Ronnie
McDaniel maiden name is Romney courtesy
of pbd co-host VI had Trump energy you
should create an an anti-matrix page
highlighting all the media lies to show
people to wake them up is that true
about Ron McDaniel's name is it was r r
Romney I don't know
or is that just a joke where they're
making fun of her that name sounds fake
first I've seen this before sounds like
a simulation that's a simulation name
for sure oh VI definitely had Trump
energy that's her stage name yeah yeah
when he called out the moderator that
his opening statement I I was saying
it's my new favorite poem it was so
beautiful I see this one uh this message
from Steve he says Marvel is turning
into representation Force sorry is is
her middle name Romney R Romney mcdel
that's what a well that would be her
maid name then yeah her maid name is
Romney R Romney
really wow y there you go well there you
go so uh the the the Marvels came out
today it's the latest film it's the
shortest Marvel film they've put out yet
it stars three super strong tough ladies
fighting an evil super strong tough lady
and uh it's the first Marvel movie I've
not gone to see and will not go see cuz
it looks bad and you know how I know
it's bad the trailer opens with footage
from endgame like the first third of the
trailer is Marvel's end end game which
was
2019 they're just recycling they're
doing it because they know that nobody
likes Brie Larson and they've invested
too much they've got a contract with
they've got to finish the movie because
it's part of the the universe so they're
they're doing something with it it went
from briarson was supposed to be the new
Iron Man to her second movie has three
main characters wow they're like we need
someone else she's not people don't like
her so they make a trailer for her movie
which I didn't even see trailers which
is crazy normally like there's tons of
trailers coming out before the movie
comes out I saw the one and it's Robert
Downey Jr and Chris Evans no joke and I
was like what what is this weren't there
multiple re-shoot of this too I don't
know probably look they were nice to us
they made it the shortest one ever and
they probably did it like we got to make
it but let's just get it done and
apparently the the critics are bombing
it like the official critics not the you
know how sad how sad but you know what
man like the MCU was a great thing they
made what was it like it was like 13
films that were all connected to each
other and then after that it was a
spattering of garbled nonsense so just
like our simulation is falling apart it
kind of parallels the MCU can only keep
Seasons going for so long probably the
same writers u r Romney McDaniel is M
Mitt Romney's niece I just got it Marvel
ended at endgame and Star Wars ended at
it's not suspicious at all yeah did she
get married or did she just change her
name like legally Mar could distance
herself from that but still be in charge
of the uni party all right the emperor's
says Tucker Carlson would be a very
prudent choice for VP he'd be able to
campaign for Trump completely negating
the last attempt to jam up the Trump uh
jam up Trump and stop him from
campaigning that's true this is the
thing you know people are saying Trump's
going to be in jail how will he how will
he campaign his VP really and if it is
someone like oh man that's why VI could
be VP because Trump could look at him
and be like okay I'm busy VI run the
show and he like if a does rallies
people are going to be cheering like
crazy yep you get phone calls from
prison though so 15 minutes a day he
could make a but here's the thing
Trump's funny I don't think V's a funny
guy he's a serious guy very serious guy
he has a hard time with that genuine
humor the Tik Tok dances are a bit much
in my opinion uh I emem rap the Eminem
rap also as a rap fan I don't really
like Eminem but he's got a do it's it's
good that he's not that guy yes he's
he's he's the the the the businessman
and Trump is the wild personality right
right and he but he still has energy
he's the only person on that stage with
any energy yeah any honesty yeah did he
have
his I know he was in charge of Co he was
on a board for something didn't he have
his uh Wikipedia page
scrubbed for I know everybody has what
I've heard too but everybody has it's
it's not surprising to me it's like one
big political competition on Wikipedia
yeah oh I've ever seen people just like
they just say George Soros and then it's
supposed to mean they just say that so
if if it's just like there are so many
people who uh they said the same thing
of trump when Trump was running they
said that he was secretly colluding with
Hillary Clinton cuz he's friends with
her and they post photos and I'm like
dude like yeah V is spreading a message
and if the argument is he's a plant who
secretly TR trying to take over oh no
he's spreading the message we like like
is the argument that he's willing that
the Deep state is sacrificing their
position to promote American first
politics and policies and anti-war mhm
and then control I I I just yeah look
man if people are spreading your message
for you just say oh no stop don't I
guess like let them do their thing he's
like moving the Overton window a bit
exactly by uh yeah with what he's saying
and he's not going to be he's not going
to win right like he maybe VP yeah could
be
fun all right d99 says I wish infringed
mention that most of these ghost guns
and crimes are just a gun that has
numbers ground off I think it is one in
five real ghost guns wow interesting
Crazy by the Fireside says I'd love I'd
love the Vue for Trump's VP if uh if
Biden is nominee only to see him ratio
comma in the debates oh God that would
be amazing yeah that would be good we
saw Tulsi body her in the debate years
ago and do it that would be I feel like
Camala would somehow try to get out of
being she might quit like you know what
I don't want to be she's like I've
really got to go back to California now
didn't today she said she had the
vocabulary and the pronunciation for the
Press did you see that no she said that
so maybe she's feeling confident now she
read a book I hope she is i' would love
to see her get bodied oh it' be great
it' be great he would he would steamroll
her Eric Sharp says D shrink this played
four years of baseball for a Yale
someone more search savvy than I should
be able to find rosters and game
programs these should show his height
and weight before presidential
aspirations well let's get it yeah
there's photos of him walking on the
beach Barefoot and he has the same
height difference with his wife then
there's a photo of her wearing high
heels and he has the same height
difference with his wife and she was
sneers the other day and he they had the
same height difference like something is
weird she was wearing sneakers at the
debate no it was like a picture of her
and um uh the Iowa governor and like
their families together he uh he was
trying to walk down a step and he
tripped do you see the video and people
are are pointing out that the reason why
his heel clipped the step is because the
the block he used to the shoes well no
no no the block object in the back of
your sh your foot you don't feel the
same way when you're walking and so he
thought he had cleared and then the he
he he moved his foot in way that his
foot would have cleared the step but the
extended heel did not the AR I want a
politician who can climb stairs why is
it so hard to find that is a little too
much to ask for come on lower your
standards right down to Ronda sanz's
height not even Nome could get
downstairs which is why he's going to be
candidate did he fall down the stairs at
the airplane on the way the other day
did he probably did it like it's not
it's all stage to make Biden look less
incomp yes that way he can lock down
that better wrer for calling little
Chinese children stairs then yes
fun fact ra McDaniel is Mitt Romney's
niece yeah see I told you guys God not
at all that's so gross does she also
like hot dogs without buns oh man Co
inspiration says Tim I have to know does
your Source in the McDaniel story own a
certain political T-Shirt Company no
comment we will not uh uh reveal any
information pertaining to our
source uh will not confirm or deny you
did see the Romney thing when he was
talking about hot dogs no he's like I
love Hot Dogs he's walking down a
hallway and then he's like I like hot
dogs in a bun I even like hot dogs
without a bun hot dogs are pretty good
I'm from Chicago it was crazy to me when
I first left Chicago and you couldn't
get hot dogs anywhere I mean for real
you go to Chicago there are hot dog
stands everywhere not stands like that's
New York New York has carts Chicago has
brick and mortar hot dog places all over
the place like Maxwell Street very
famous but you like walk down the street
and it's when I was a kid and me and my
friends were playing in a his like our
garage band we would walk four blocks to
the hot dog shop and you'd walk inside
and it's hot dogs and burgers and
Italian beef and the signs are all for
hot dogs like Chicago is all about hot
dogs and then I moved uh I I bounced
around and visited a bunch of places and
it's just like there's nothing and I was
like Wow and it was a crazy moment for
me when I was in um where was I I think
I was in LA no no I was in New York and
I went to get a sub I went to get
they're called heroes in New York not
Subs right and uh when I was asked what
I wanted on it I said I want to do uh
roast beef cheddar and jardinera and he
went and what and I was like roast beef
cheddar and jardinera and he goes J what
jardinera he's like hey we don't have
that I was like what and then I found I
found out it's a Chicago thing yeah we
don't have that in New York don't have
that in New York not in LA but because
of pot bellies you get them called
they're called hot peppers right and so
I figured out how to get them and so
here at the castle we just ordered like
30 of them cuz I'm like if you're from
Chicago you're wondering what's going on
that's hilarious why can't I get good
food out of here yo the best thing ever
is a janire pizza H yeah I'll try it
people should look up what jardinera is
good luck spelling it I don't even know
how to spell it g i a d i n r a jardena
i can't spell it good
luck yeah but it's awesome it's it's
great it's like celery carrots
cauliflower and jalapenos and oil that
sounds
amazing
yeah all
right
uh let's see Nick says I am a member I
don't have the time to watch anymore I
will never not give y'all 10 bucks a
month thank you for what you do love you
guys really do appreciate it we we we
definitely do do advocacy and stuff
we're like we're like a weird mix of
like Mission driven media and stuff it's
a fair point a lot of people who are
members are doing it just because they
like what we continue to do and I I
embrace it I'm like look man if you
like uh if you like second amendment
rights we I just set uh $100,000
marketing Budget on social media like
set as in like I literally clicked go
and the money is currently and actively
being spent the ads are running and
these ads are for advocacy uh on gun
rights but it's like it's for the
documentary we won't be able to sign up
we want to watch the documentary if at
the very least all we get out of it is
we have made a pro gun rights
documentary ubiquitous through you know
this marketing campaign there you go if
we can get more members if we can make
more money I would love to spend a
million dollars marketing gun rights
documentary just like with DA wire and
what is a woman right we're going to
make documentaries that support the
ideas we believe in and uh that's why
you should become a member at
timcast.net
and permit I regret not getting involved
before the sweeping banss right on man
right
on all right we'll grab some more
neglectful sausage say says Tim that's
part of it except Millennials also were
the first generation to not be uh pushed
to work at 14 to 15 years old and now
people are saying 21 are still kids it's
infantilization of uh by our culture
itself but you do it too re consent law
what what does that mean I mean not
everyone we can't hear anything you're
saying bro oh M oh sorry not everyone
because I was referring uh soccer games
when I was what 14 15 so like not I
didn't knew kids were doing the same
thing so not every Millennial was like
that I don't don't totally agree with
that no we got plenty of 14-year-olds
bagging groceries out of grocery stores
yeah there there's definitely there're
out there but it is true that a lot of
uh a lot of Millennials were not getting
jobs very true yeah yeah my oldest I
mean he's he's a go-getter he actually
uh he buys broken gaming systems and
fixes them goes through solders things
and sells them back to the local flea
market that's awesome that's very cool
ready to rumble says Tim has never been
in a fight in his entire life false I
mean that's just ridiculous everybody
you you been in a fight fight oh yeah
yeah have you been in a fight it's my
hobby I used to do uh um I I briefly
took it depends on what you mean by
fight for sure but I've been in actual
fights where it was wild and uh a kid
dded me once when I was in grade school
DDT yeah cuz like WWE was so big and we
got into a fight and I I don't watch WWE
so I was just swinging and then he
grabbed me and then he did it it didn't
hurt at all and I was confused as to
what happened but everyone thought it
was a big deal and I got into a fight in
grade school uh and I've gotten into a
bunch of fights when I was older but
like you know few and far between Watch
the watch the live streams where I'm
fighting with antifa there's a photo of
me and Luke fighting with an antifa guy
and it was it was printed in like New
York daily news or something so this guy
smacked my hand and I grabbed him and
then I was surrounded by cops so I just
locked his arm and and he tried to get
away and I wouldn't let him and then
Luke pulled his mask off and then
everyone got pictures of his face and so
I don't know it depends on what you mean
by fight yeah no I do J Jitsu couple
days a week I trained Gracie Bradon you
should definitely come train with me if
anyone is ever in town but does is that
what someone means by being in a fight
though you know what I mean it's a fight
you're getting chok street fight though
it's not but it's not the same like
they're not trying to actually hurt you
they're trying to win a fight and you
tap out and they say okay like maybe
they mean this person means by fight as
in you're in the middle of the street
and some dude's trying to Stomp Your
Head on the you got to know yeah to how
to define it cuz you're not trying to
kill the person i' I've been jumped I've
been hit in the head I've been in
different fights whether it was like our
little fight club we had throughout
middle school and high school where you
schedule this fight with this guy and
your bare knuckle punch each other in
the face or uh you're getting jumped by
the football team or you're at a
ju-jitsu match you know um or you're in
a mosh pit where everyone's throwing
their fists around and you leave with a
broken KN or nose like I did for a long
time I guess it depends what a fight is
you know yeah it depends if you're
talking about like a stre yeah but it's
different than like than like actually
being sanctioned in any way that's for
sure it's still a fight though I oh yeah
I'm not saying it's not a fight for sure
but but yeah different different uh I
guess you could say different
environment caus well it won I think it
was UFC 1 2 and four and they had to
change the rules because gju won the
first four so and if that's not
simulating fighting and winning in
actual fighting I don't know y yeah hell
yeah all right Aaron James says Tim
please shout out the Millennials who
aren't lazy those who are getting
married working hard raising kids
starting businesses like my wife coach
Sophie James helping people manage real
work life balance I'm not saying all
Millennials the reason why I say
millennials Su is because we have a
disproportionate amount of lazy in like
just awful people in the millennial
generation yeah but of course I think
the majority of Millennials are normal
work hard we're raised well it's just
that we we're getting it's a growing
body I think it's going to revert back
with Gen Z and then the population's
going to collapse after that so jz's
totally screwed yo this world is going
to be Millennial it's like if you think
it's bad not the Boomers control the
wealth wait till Millennials are are 50
to is 60 years old and there is no gen
Alpha because people aren't having kids
so gen Alpha is going to be really small
people who are marketing going to say
what's the point of marketing to a
microscopic uh uh target market you'll
make they'll have some companies but
this is going to be the death of culture
a large component of it is no incentive
towards making new things because gen
Alpha is too small and Millennials are
too big so if I'm going look we did a we
did a gun rights documentary we're
looking at running commercials where
should I run the commercials a
reasonable marketing marketing decision
is have these commercial commercials run
on channels that like guns because then
people are going are going to want to
watch but like hold on there a minute
what's the point of that they'll know
this already and they already so but
they'll like it and they're more likely
to buy it oh okay that's not the mission
so what what is the ad we're running on
on Google all just anywhere in the
United States on any kind of content 18
and up Let the commercial run and it
means we'll make less money but I'm not
trying to get a bunch of people who
already agree with me to watch something
so we can all pet each other on the back
that's stupid but this is what's going
to happen in the future a guy's going to
be like I got a million bucks to invest
I want to make at least a million bucks
back on top okay well if we go for Jan
Alpha I don't know you might you might
make 1.3 okay what about what about Jen
Z 1.7 what about Millennials 3 million
okay if I can make if I can triple my
money off Millennials what kind of bands
do we got to get oh got to get the
oldies the classics you know like
Smashing Pumpkins okay then they do and
then the new upand cominging bands are
not getting paid they're not getting
hired for gigs because they don't sell
enough tickets that's just it is Gen
Alpha going to be able to fill a 4,000
seat venue are they going to be able to
fill a
stadium probably not yeah probably not
it's going to be aging like look blink
82 just came out with a new album and
it's like doing really well there like
their album's doing really well cuz
because Nostalgia sells it's not
absolutely
but with population decline narrowing
down even young people what's going to
happen is you're going to have some some
20-year-old businessman Millennials are
going to be in their 50s and 60s and
this 20-year-old dude's going to be like
I make a bunch of money selling Rolling
Stones
t-shirts that's it I mean already gen Z
wearing Nirvana shirts I think is funny
like I think you died after Kurt Cobain
but it's cool that you're wearing three
songs name three songs that's what no
there was that viral video where the one
was like I don't even know what this is
remember that she wearing yeah she was
like they they were selling it at the
mall and I bought like what is it yep
yeah and then she played it for the
first time like is that what this is wow
wow we're
old all right what do we
got thick Mick uh C run fast says Trump
is the guy playing Roy in that episode
of Rick and Morty where someone goes
dude this guy is taking Roy Off the Grid
reference to Blitz and chits yo the new
Rick and Morty is painfully bad I know
cuz they got rid of that guy right the
guy who made it I don't understand how
we would have shows like like this
doesn't make any sense the best part is
that he is now basically found innocent
as far as everyone can tell he nothing
has happened to him people are still are
still dragging him over some leaked
messages I don't know a whole lot about
but the the real accusations that got
him fired from everything was domestic
abuse that was proven false it was
proven false that's amazing funniest
part they're TR it the funny thing is uh
so Justin Ryland voiced like most of the
characters he voiced Rick and Morty
they've replaced him and there the first
few episodes had no Morty in
because the dude just suck doing the
voice and now the episode with Morty it
sounds like the dude after he voices
Morty is gasping and wheezing cuz he's
struggling and straining himself to do
this
voice the The Voice like yeah the
current voice of Morty sounds like he's
always got to stick up his ass yeah it's
just like it's it's it's an agitated way
to do the voice and it's just like oh
this is so miserable I won't watch it it
ended for me it's over yeah it's over
it's over it's like you with with the
Marvels like I for me end game was the
end thank you very much I appreciate
that the same thing with Star Wars like
six was the last one everything else not
fan fiction yeah it's all fan fiction
mhm yeah sometimes things have to come
to an end I mean I hate to say that and
partially with Rick and Morty it's sort
of an unfair because it was premature
but things can't last forever
unfortunately and sometimes it's better
to stop I'll reference one of my
favorite shows Gilmore Girls where the
writer and producer and her husband got
into a huge debate with the studio and
so they left over the sixth season and a
lot of people who watch it just don't
watch the last one because it wasn't
written so it's not the same feel I I
got an idea we're going to create the
timcast documentary universe and what we
would do is at the end of infringed
after the credits it shows like you know
Lauren sitting at a bar drinking and
then like Benny Johnson will walk in or
something and he'll be like I need to
show you something about this and then
he slides like a voting report to her
and then it's like cuz that's what MCU
all all it really was was they were
marketing their next movie yeah and then
they decided later like I guess they're
all in the same universe let's connect
them and we'll do the Avengers and it
turned into a universe do that was great
they were making people wait for that
dopamine dump though you were waiting a
couple years in between movies I I think
that's what I loved about those post
scen credits it's like forced uh what's
the word uh forced graic forced delayed
gratification some of the end scenes
don't even make sense anymore so they
stopped making sense like at the end of
uh I think at the end of Hulk
uh was it the end of Hulk you get uh the
general meeting with Robert Dy Jr and it
was like signaling Iron Man or whatever
but I don't know I think Iron Man was
first I don't know whatever and then was
first so then what was what movie and
what was before there was a movie that
ends and it shows them talking to Robert
Dy maybe that was the Hulk it was for
part two or something but uh it used to
be like you know uh after I think
Captain America or something or one
movie they find Thor's hammer or
whatever so it was a direct hey this
movie is next there was a what there was
one movie that ended and it was like
Harry Styles was there and everyone's
like oh and then like nothing happened
with that and everyone I trying to make
that guy relevant yeah I I was like I
guess he's here you know that was I
swear to God if they ruin Deadpool 3 I'm
just oh man yeah I'll go see that one I
will go walk the building all right
everybody if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends head over to Tim
cast.com become a member to watch the
uncensored members only show and check
out the documentary infringed we're
going to be hanging out with you and
taking your calls you can talk to us and
our guests going to be a lot of fun you
can follow show at timcast you can
follow me person at timcast Adam do you
want to sh anything out um I'm on X
exclusively Facebook uh got rid of my
account again for some unowned reason so
I'm on X exclusively I'm at lecturn
leader so come give me a follow a lot of
satire you probably hate most of what I
say but that's who I am awesome it was
awesome doing the show with you man
awesome to meet you uh I'm mat Shane
Cashman everywhere my next story that I
got coming up I I got to spend the day
with NWA wrestlers that was a crazy day
shout out to Billy Corgan and the
world's heavyweight champion EC3 who's
probably watching right now they let me
hang around uh see a lot of cool stuff
talk a lot of cool pro wrestlers and uh
I I see a little distinction between uh
pro wrestling world and also American
politics so I'm looking forward to
sharing that with everybody pretty soon
that's awesome you can find that at
timcast news you go to
timcast.net
I'm a writer for timcast news follow @
timcast news on Instagram and x and if
you want to follow me personally I'm on
Instagram at han. and I'm on X at hcbo
guys thank you so much bye Serge bye-bye
hanac Clair uh I am happy with today's
epode it was fun pleasure to see you as
always uh and I am excited for the after
show let's do this we'll see you all
over at timcast.net